I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Oh boy. It's a big one today.
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你们制作《办公室》终极重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是“办公室女士”。天哪。今天这一集很重要。
That's what she said. I mean, I didn't even say hello. Hello. Say hello first. I mean, I'm just thinking about everything we have to share about Niagara, the wedding episode. The enormous two-parter. We're doing it in two parts.
那是她说的。我是说，我还没打招呼呢。你好。先打个招呼。我是说，我一直在想关于尼亚加拉，也就是婚礼那一集，我们有很多要分享的。那可是个巨大的两集连播。我们分两部分来做。
This is so big. Oh yeah. Today is Niagara part one. It was season six episode four. It was written by Greg Daniels and Mindy Kaling and directed by Paul Feig. I mean, we brought out the heavy hitters for this one. We sure did. And we have a heavy hitter today on Office Ladies.
这太重要了。没错。今天是尼亚加拉第一部分。这是第六季第四集。由格雷格·丹尼尔斯和敏迪·卡灵编剧，保罗·费格执导。我是说，我们为这一集请来了重量级人物。我们确实请到了。而且今天在“办公室女士”节目中，我们有一位重量级嘉宾。
We sure do, guys. Co-writer of this episode and showrunner of The Office, Greg Daniels has come on Office Ladies to discuss this epic milestone episode. We could not be more excited. We are thrilled. Let's talk to Greg. Greg Daniels. Hello.
我们确实有，伙计们。本集的联合编剧兼《办公室》剧集主管格雷格·丹尼尔斯来到了“办公室女士”，讨论这一史诗般的里程碑式剧集。我们感到无比兴奋。我们太激动了。让我们和格雷格聊聊。格雷格·丹尼尔斯。你好。
Hey. Welcome. This is a huge treat. We are so excited to have you on Office Ladies. Oh yeah, for me too. It's so nice to see you guys. And this is a milestone episode. Big one.
嘿。欢迎。这真是一份大礼。我们非常高兴你能来到“办公室女士”。哦，我也是。见到你们真好。这是一集里程碑式的剧集。很重要的一集。
Very big one. Jen and I were saying just prepping our document for this week's record. We felt like we were building like a small airplane because there was like so many different stories and articles and DVD commentaries and we're just so glad you're here and we get to break it down with you. I went back into the archives, you know, and looked at some of our notes from the writer's room and, you know, I realized that we had gained this one so thoroughly from the beginning. This was like my special point of the season, obviously.
非常重要。珍和我在为这周的录音准备文档时说，我们感觉就像在造一架小飞机，因为有太多不同的故事、文章和DVD评论，我们很高兴你能来，能和你一起剖析这一集。我回到档案里看了看我们在编剧室的一些笔记，我意识到我们从一开始就非常彻底地构思了这一集。这显然是我这一季的特别重点。
This was like the biggest moment that we had, so we had really put a lot of effort and thought into it. Randy Cordray told us that before season six even started, you told him Pam and Jim are going to get married on the maid of the mist. Figure that out. Yeah. Yeah. So this was a crazy year for me personally because this was the first year that I had
这是我们拥有的最重大的时刻，所以我们确实投入了大量的精力和思考。兰迪·科德雷告诉我们，在第六季开始之前，你就告诉他，帕姆和吉姆要在雾中少女号上结婚。想办法实现它。是的。是的。所以对我个人来说，这是疯狂的一年，因为这是我第一年
an official co-show runner in Paul Lieberstein, you know, and I was also running season two of Parks and Rec at the same time as season six of The Office with Mike Scher, and there was, we had like the biggest juiciest writing staff possible, like this was like one of our classic year's writing staff. Everybody was great, so there was a lot of help, but I think I did 50 episodes this year. Oh my gosh. Between the two shows, which is like 50 table readings, 50 script blocks, 50 production meetings, 50 cuts having to be locked.
有保罗·利伯斯坦作为正式的联合剧集主管，而且我当时还在和迈克·舒尔同时制作《公园与游憩》第二季和《办公室》第六季，我们拥有尽可能最强大、最精彩的编剧团队，这就像我们编剧团队的经典年份之一。每个人都很棒，所以得到了很多帮助，但我认为我今年做了50集。天哪。在两部剧之间，相当于50次剧本围读、50个剧本大纲、50次制作会议、50次需要锁定的剪辑。
So I was like super crazed for this year, and the things that I really wanted to concentrate on for The Office was Jim and Pam's wedding because I felt like this was the culmination of a six-year story that was so important to the show, and so we put a lot of brainwork into it. And with the Niagara part, that was like what I had sort of figured out for the wedding because the wedding had to be filled with comedy for all of the side characters, but it also had to be very romantic for Jim and Pam, and the show always had this slight anomaly that was Jim and Pam because it was so fairytale inside their relationship, but then everything
所以我今年超级疯狂，我真正想为《办公室》集中精力的是吉姆和帕姆的婚礼，因为我觉得这是六年来对该剧非常重要的故事的高潮，所以我们投入了很多脑力。关于尼亚加拉的部分，那是我为婚礼想出的点子，因为婚礼必须为所有配角充满喜剧色彩，但对吉姆和帕姆来说也必须非常浪漫，而且该剧一直有一个轻微的异常，那就是吉姆和帕姆，因为他们的关系太像童话了，但随后剧中的一切
else in the show was up for grabs for jokes and, you know, was very realistic. And Niagara Falls is within a drive, like a conceivable four-and-a-half-hour drive of Scranton, so it made sense that you could invite people from work and they would drive up, you know, and it was a doable thing. And so I did a lot of research on Niagara Falls way early, and what's amazing about Niagara Falls is it's like the most classic wedding location for people, you know, in the Northeast, and it's been that way since the 1800s or whenever it was discovered, and it's incredibly naturally beautiful and like take your breath away, majestic, but because
其他事情都可以拿来开玩笑，而且非常现实。尼亚加拉大瀑布距离斯克兰顿只有大约四个半小时的车程，所以邀请同事们开车去那里是有道理的，这是一件可行的事情。所以我很早就对尼亚加拉大瀑布做了很多研究，尼亚加拉大瀑布最神奇的地方在于，它是东北部人们最经典的婚礼地点，自1800年代或它被发现以来一直如此，它自然美得令人窒息，雄伟壮观，但因为
everybody used it as their wedding thing, there was this really kind of commercialized, like, kitschy industry that had developed around it, so it was like a great location because you could have, you know, for the one sort of thing we had going into it was this idea that, I don't know if you were ever told this on your guys' weddings, but, you know, they always say like, the wedding is for your family and the marriage is what you get, and there's this sense of like, the wedding is this public event and you have to invite your family and all these different people, and it's not always exactly what you wanted, but at least you get the marriage, right?
每个人都把它当作婚礼地点，所以围绕它发展出了一种非常商业化、俗气的产业，所以这是一个很棒的地点，因为你可以，你知道，我们进入这一集时有一个想法，我不知道你们在婚礼时是否被告知过，但人们总是说，婚礼是为你家人办的，而婚姻是你自己得到的，有一种感觉是，婚礼是一个公共活动，你必须邀请家人和各种各样的人，这并不总是你想要的，但至少你得到了婚姻，对吧？
So I think there was this going into the episode, there was going to be this sort of two things happening where Pam and Jim wanted to have something that was beautiful and romantic for the two of them, but they also had to, you know, they had all these obligations with their family and their people from work, and that was going to have all these people there. So there was this contrast between like the comedy of having all their relatives and, you know, Pam's mother was upset, you know, and their parents had gotten divorced, and you know, the fact that Pam was pregnant and kind of hiding it, like there are all these different storylines happening for comedy.
所以我认为在这一集之前，会有两件事同时发生，帕姆和吉姆想为他们俩举办一场美丽而浪漫的婚礼，但他们也必须，你知道，他们对家人和同事有各种义务，而且会有很多人在那里。所以这与喜剧形成了对比，比如他们所有的亲戚都在那里，帕姆的母亲很心烦，他们的父母离婚了，而且帕姆怀孕了还在隐瞒，有很多不同的故事情节在发生，为了喜剧效果。
And Greg, I love that it was the destination wedding because on the commentary you were saying a lot of different elements of this episode were based on real life things in the writer's room, like the destination wedding that you think no one will come to, but then a lot of people show up. Yeah. And then there was like, there was a moment that I pulled from a friend of mine's wedding story where I guess his sister, by mistake, broke one of the wedding gifts, which was like a set of plates or something like that, that they had registered for, and she was
格雷格，我喜欢这是目的地婚礼，因为在评论中你说这一集的许多不同元素都是基于编剧室的真实事件，比如你认为没人会来的目的地婚礼，但结果很多人都来了。是的。还有一个时刻是我从我朋友的婚礼故事中借鉴的，我想他的妹妹不小心打碎了其中一份结婚礼物，那是一套他们登记过的盘子之类的东西，她当时
super upset about it, and my friend couldn't really calmer down until he took one of the other plates and smashed it in front of her and said, look, this is not about the plates. I want you to, you know, enjoy my wedding. And so that, that kind of translated into Jim cutting his tie to make Pam feel better. That is such a cool moment. Yeah, I love that moment, yeah. I teared up. I, you know, there were so many wonderful moments that I had just forgotten about about
超级难过，我朋友直到拿起另一个盘子在她面前摔碎并说，看，这与盘子无关。我希望你享受我的婚礼，才让她平静下来。这转化为吉姆剪掉领带让帕姆感觉好些。那真是一个很酷的时刻。是的，我喜欢那个时刻。我热泪盈眶。我，你知道，有太多美妙的时刻我差点就忘记了
this episode. I think when I think of this episode too, I always think about the big wedding moment. I completely forgot about the cold. Yeah. Oh yeah. The cold opened. I was like, what is happening? It's a dozen people puking to open up the romantic wedding episode.
这一集。我想当我想到这一集时，我总是想到那个盛大的婚礼时刻。我完全忘记了那个冷开场。是的。哦，是的。那个冷开场。我当时想，发生了什么？在浪漫的婚礼剧集开头，有十几个人在呕吐。
Yeah. Well, I mean, that was the thing, right, is like, we had so many cards on the board for ideas, you know, for the season and for this important, you know, episode, and this was also a two-part episode, which meant that there had to be like six acts of story, right? So, and a lot of different people, they didn't have their own subplot, you know, wasn't like, oh, well, don't worry, Andy and Michael are having a subplot where they're selling to some, you know, they're there at the wedding. So they all have to have their own comedy stories.
是的。嗯，我是说，这就是重点，对吧，我们在板上有太多的想法卡片，为了这一季和这一重要的剧集，而且这也是一个两集连播的剧集，这意味着必须有六幕故事，对吧？所以，很多不同的人，他们没有自己的副线，不是说，哦，别担心，安迪和迈克有一个副线，他们在卖东西，他们在婚礼上。所以他们都必须有自己的喜剧故事。
So we generated in the writer's room, you know, just hundreds of cards of funny things that could happen. And then we had to kind of jam them all, you know, into the overall feeling of a destination wedding in Niagara. That was the whole thing about the episode was balancing how much comedy to put in and how much romance and good feeling to put in. Well, one of my favorite things is this agreement that everyone's going to keep Pam's pregnancy a secret from Mima.
所以我们在编剧室里生成了数百张关于可能发生的有趣事情的卡片。然后我们不得不把它们全部塞进尼亚加拉目的地婚礼的整体感觉中。这就是这一集的全部内容，平衡喜剧和浪漫以及良好的感觉。嗯，我最喜欢的事情之一是每个人都同意对米玛隐瞒帕姆怀孕的消息。
We're not going to tell Mima. Like what a disaster already that, right, that Michael's not going to be able to keep the secret. We all think Michael's going to spill the beans. Well, first of all, I have a question about the name Mima. Was that, was that based on someone's real life? I had never heard that. I've heard like Grammy, Gigi as names for grandma's, but Mima was new to me.
我们不打算告诉米玛。这已经是一场灾难了，对吧，迈克尔无法保守秘密。我们都认为迈克尔会说漏嘴。嗯，首先，我有一个关于“米玛”这个名字的问题。这是基于某人的真实生活吗？我以前从未听说过。我听说过像“格莱美”、“吉吉”这样的祖母名字，但“米玛”对我来说是新的。
Is that an East Coast thing? I don't think so. I think that's like a pioneer thing personally. I kind of feel like that's a world-west thing. I've heard of Mima. Is it Southern? I think it might be Southern or I think like what Greg's saying, kind of like ye olde pioneer days.
这是东海岸的叫法吗？我不这么认为。我个人觉得这更像是先驱者的叫法。我感觉这更像是西部地区的叫法。我听说过“米玛”。是南方的吗？我想可能是南方的，或者像格雷格说的，有点像老派先驱时代。
But my dad was called Paw Paw. Yeah. Well, we might have gotten it from you. Did you have a Mima? I didn't have a Mima, but it's certainly like when I read it, I was like, sure, you're Mima. Yeah. Like it's in my brain somewhere.
但我爸爸被称为“波波”。是的。嗯，我们可能是从你那里学来的。你有“米玛”吗？我没有“米玛”，但当我读到它时，我肯定会想，当然，你是“米玛”。就像它在我脑海里的某个地方。
Well, I mean, the idea was that she was pretty old fashioned person who was going to be, you know, pretty judgmental. The actress was kind of amazing. She started in Westerns in the 1930s, that actress Peggy Stewart. So she, I think, was a Mima. Well, it ends up being Jim in just a brilliant piece of writing and performance then by John Krasinski, who ends up spilling the beans. I loved it.
嗯，我的意思是，这个想法是她是一个相当老派的人，会相当爱评判别人。那位女演员非常了不起。她从1930年代就开始演西部片了，那位女演员佩吉·斯图尔特。所以我想她就是一位“米玛”。嗯，最后是吉姆，在约翰·卡拉辛斯基精彩的剧本和表演下，最终说漏了嘴。我喜欢它。
Yeah. Just brilliant. Yeah, that was great. I don't think we started with that. I feel like we got to that eventually that it was going to be Jim that blew it. I can't remember exactly how that started, but yeah, no, it was great because you were expecting Michael to do it the whole time. Yeah.
是的。太精彩了。是的，那太棒了。我不认为我们一开始就这么设定。我觉得我们最终确定是吉姆搞砸了。我不记得具体是怎么开始的，但是的，这很棒，因为你一直期待迈克尔会说漏嘴。是的。
And I just rewatched it this morning and God, John was so funny blowing it in his toast. So good. Because he was doing so well up to there too. He was really killing it. Well, and then they have that great exchange where Michael says, this really takes the pressure off of me. Yeah. Like, this is great.
我今天早上刚重温了一遍，天哪，约翰在祝酒词中搞砸的样子太搞笑了。太棒了。因为他在那之前表现得很好。他真的表现得很出色。嗯，然后他们有那段精彩的对话，迈克尔说，这真的减轻了我的压力。是的。就像，这太棒了。
Jim's like, I can't believe it was me. And Michael's like, I can't believe it either. Yeah. Yeah, that was great. I mean, there was some great act breaks, right? So we needed to have like six act breaks or something. And another huge, huge thing was the act break of Jim and Pam running away because that was pretty big too.
吉姆说，我不敢相信是我。迈克尔说，我也不敢相信。是的。是的，那太棒了。我的意思是，有一些很棒的幕间休息，对吧？所以我们需要有六个幕间休息之类的。另一个巨大、巨大的事情是吉姆和帕姆逃跑的幕间休息，因为那也相当大。
That felt like a romantic comedy to me. That moment, you know, it really did. It was so just everything, the lighting and they ran away. And then I love that you didn't see Meredith smoking the cigar. Yeah. It's just this, this like beautiful moment and then there's Meredith, you know. Well speaking of romantic comedy, you wrote this episode with Mindy Kaling. You guys were nominated for an Emmy for this episode.
那对我来说感觉像是一部浪漫喜剧。那一刻，你知道，确实如此。一切，灯光，他们跑开了。然后我喜欢你没有看到梅雷迪思抽雪茄。是的。这只是一个美丽的时刻，然后是梅雷迪思。说到浪漫喜剧，你和敏迪·卡灵一起写了这一集。你们因这一集获得了艾美奖提名。
How did it come about that you guys wrote this together? Well, you know, it's interesting. Mindy is such a lover of romantic comedy and I'm not a hundred percent sure. I kind of feel like I had identified that she ought to write it. And then I was giving so many specific suggestions that there was this feeling of, well, you got a really strong feeling of how you want it to go. Maybe you should co-write it. So I feel like I came into it that way.
你们是怎么想到一起写这一集的？嗯，你知道，这很有趣。敏迪是浪漫喜剧的忠实爱好者，我不太确定。我感觉我认定她应该写这一集。然后我给出了太多具体的建议，以至于有一种感觉，好吧，你对它应该怎么发展有非常强烈的感受。也许你应该合写。所以我感觉我是那样参与进来的。
And of course, you know, so many of the beats were coming from these cards that we had generated as a team. I mean, in re-reading the table draft, I was loving the first half so much. I feel like that must have probably been her, her stuff because I have to take responsibility for Roy and the horse. Okay. Please. Okay.
当然，你知道，许多节拍都来自我们作为一个团队生成的卡片。我的意思是，在重读剧本草稿时，我非常喜欢前半部分。我觉得那一定是她的东西，因为我必须为罗伊和马负责。好的。请。好的。
How do we even set it up? Roy and the horse and the falls, Greg, you have to tell the whole story. Right. And I said, you know, so much of it was balancing how much comedy to put in and how much joy to put in. And definitely I wanted to have that theme of there's all these things going wrong in the wedding, but Pam and Jim managed to carve out this beautiful, private moment anyway. Right?
我们该怎么设定呢？罗伊、马和瀑布，格雷格，你必须讲完整个故事。好的，我说过，很大程度上是在平衡喜剧和快乐。我绝对想有一个主题，那就是婚礼上出了这么多问题，但帕姆和吉姆还是设法开辟了这个美丽的私人时刻。对吧？
Right. So the table draft had an act break where to top off all of these things that had been going wrong, like finding out about the pregnancy and Andy scrotum, Michael and Pam's mom. Yeah. That was positive. But to top it all off, like Roy shows up on a horse to try and make a grand gesture of take me back and it's just goes terribly. And you know, this was a card that we had on the board, you know, early on about, you
对。所以剧本草稿有一个幕间休息，为了给所有这些出错的事情画上句号，比如发现怀孕、安迪的阴囊、迈克尔和帕姆的妈妈。是的。那是积极的。但最重要的是，罗伊骑着马出现，试图做一个“带我回去”的宏大姿态，结果却糟糕透顶。你知道，这是我们板上早就有的一张卡片，关于
know, like those things when those things happen in romantic comedy movies, they usually work and how awkward is it when it doesn't work and nobody wanted it and nobody was rooting for it. And, you know, you have to just ride your horse away. And in the table draft, Greg, Roy rides in the church and Jim is saying to have him to hold in sickness and in health and there's like an audible like, and there's Roy on a horse. Yeah.
你知道，当浪漫喜剧电影中发生这些事情时，它们通常会奏效，而当它不奏效且没人支持、没人看好时，那是多么尴尬。而且，你必须骑着马离开。在剧本草稿中，格雷格，罗伊骑马进入教堂，吉姆正在说“无论疾病还是健康”，然后有一个清晰的，罗伊骑着马。是的。
So Pam really is like, I don't, I don't want this. No, she had no interest. I'm picking the man I love and I guess thank you, but can you turn your horse around? Yeah. So, but I think what, what it was in that script was it was ordered differently. It was like everything goes wrong at the wedding and then, and Michael's having the worst day and then Jim gets the idea, I'm going to take Pam away and do it right. And he leaves Michael in charge and then, and then there was in the script, there were
所以帕姆真的觉得，我不，我不想要这个。不，她没兴趣。我选择了我的爱人，我想谢谢你，但你能把马转过去吗？是的。所以，但我认为那个剧本里的东西是顺序不同的。就像婚礼上一切都出错了，迈克尔度过了最糟糕的一天，然后吉姆想到了，我要带帕姆离开，把它做对。他让迈克尔负责，然后，剧本里有
like sort of two montages. There was the montage of Jim and Pam getting married on the maid of the mist and then there was the montage of Michael kind of killing it as being put in charge of the party and Oh, right. Because they got married in the church first in the table draft and then they have a second wedding while everybody else is at the reception. Yeah. Yeah.
大约两个蒙太奇。一个是吉姆和帕姆在雾中少女号上结婚的蒙太奇，另一个是迈克尔在负责派对时表现出色的蒙太奇，哦，对了。因为他们在剧本草稿中先在教堂结婚，然后当其他人在招待会时，他们举行了第二次婚礼。是的。是的。
I have to mention the other part about the horse, which was there was a runner in that version where Dwight was fascinated being at Niagara Falls about the, the 1800s and the and the history of people going over the falls in a barrel and animals surviving going over the falls. Yes. In a way that, that people couldn't. And so after, after Roy does this whole thing, Dwight sees a free horse and decides he's going to test this out and he takes the horse into the river and then he starts to getting
我必须提到关于马的另一部分，那个版本里有一个情节，德怀特对尼亚加拉大瀑布非常着迷，关于1800年代以及人们坐木桶过瀑布和动物在瀑布中幸存的历史。是的。以一种人们无法做到的方式。所以，在罗伊做了这一切之后，德怀特看到了一匹免费的马，决定他要测试一下，他把马带进了河里，然后他开始被
swept towards the falls and he panics and he has to be rescued. But the horse goes over the falls, you know, and then at the end, the horse is okay, swimming away from the falls because he survived like some animals do. But you would have seen him as Jim and Pam are doing their second romantic wedding on maid of the mist. In the background. You just see it like a tiny horse, going over, over the falls behind. Yeah.
冲向瀑布，他惊慌失措，不得不被救。但马掉进了瀑布，你知道，最后，马没事，从瀑布里游了出来，因为它像一些动物一样幸存了下来。但当吉姆和帕姆在雾中少女号上举行第二次浪漫婚礼时，你会看到它。在背景中。你只是看到它像一匹小马，在瀑布后面掉下去。是的。
Yeah. That was the concept. So anyway, so we read it at the table. There was an awful lot of comedy in the script. And I think we had just sort of over stack the comedy and under stack the joy and the, you know, because there was just too much bad things happening to poor Pam and Jim. And they had their great moment on the maid of the mist still, but everything that was public was kind of a disaster.
是的。这就是概念。所以，无论如何，我们在围读时读了它。剧本里有太多的喜剧。我觉得我们只是把喜剧堆得太多，而把快乐和感觉堆得太少，因为对可怜的帕姆和吉姆来说发生了太多糟糕的事情。他们仍然在雾中少女号上有了伟大的时刻，但所有公开的事情都是一场灾难。
And I think there was this very smart feeling from, you know, everybody, especially cast that that was not cool. Like you got to give them more joy. The amount of the emotional balance and the episode was off. And also, like, I think the cast that was all, you know, they were all friends and there we had done so many episodes of them sort of turning into a family that it was, you just didn't want to be that negative and play them all as problems for Pam and Jim, right? So that was sort of the message after the table read, but I was still producing.
我认为每个人，尤其是演员，都有一个非常聪明的感受，那就是这不酷。你必须给他们更多的快乐。这一集的情感平衡不对。而且，我认为演员们，你知道，他们都是朋友，我们已经拍了这么多集他们变成一家人的戏，你只是不想那么消极，把他们都当作帕姆和吉姆的问题，对吧？所以这就是围读后的信息，但我当时还在制作。
And I remember going to scout the tank at Universal where the horse was going to be filmed in the water, because that was like a big, big deal. And like, I knew that we had to fix this, but I was still having to produce, you know, the diversion until it got changed. And I came back from that and Paul luckily had pulled this other card that we had had about, you know, the YouTube sensation forever song and figured out a way to put that in at the end. And the key of it was sort of intercutting so that they could have, they went to the,
我记得去环球影城的坦克里勘景，马将在那里拍摄，因为那是一件大事。我知道我们必须解决这个问题，但我仍然不得不制作，你知道，直到它被改变。我从那里回来，保罗幸运地拿出了我们有的另一张关于YouTube轰动歌曲《Forever》的卡片，并想出了一种方法在最后把它放进去。关键在于交叉剪辑，这样他们可以，他们在教堂场景之前就去结婚了，对吧？所以我找到了我们的节拍表，围读后关于如何重新排序结尾的新节拍表，它有那个交叉剪辑的东西。这就是摆脱马的关键。所以我终于可以释放那匹马了，因为我们有了结局。嗯，我在重温时看到走廊里的那段舞蹈场景时哭了。那很感人。我想格雷格，这是因为你所说的，我们在现实生活中是朋友，我们都爱上了这段虚构的浪漫，我们想作为一个群体一起庆祝这个里程碑。所以我看到了这种混合，我的意思是，就像我看到德怀特在走廊里跳舞，我也看到了雷恩在走廊里跳舞。所以对我来说，这更具冲击力和情感。这太快乐了。我的意思是，拍摄它真的很快乐，看着它也是。是的。
they went and got married before the church scene, right? So I have, I found like our, our beat sheet, our new beat sheet after the table for how to reorder the end and it had that intercutting thing. And that was the key to getting rid of the horse. So I could finally release the horse as we had an ending. Well, I just wept when I watched that dance scene down the aisle in my rewatch. It was emotional. And I think Greg, it's because of what you said, which is that we were friends in real
我的意思是，这就是该剧的制作方式，对吧？我的意思是，我们并不是带着一个版本的想法进入它的。该剧确实因为每个人的创意投入、片场发生的事情以及剪辑室里的事情而发生了很大变化，围读草稿与最终剪辑不太相似并不完全罕见。我的意思是，那是过程的一部分。这是真的。你知道，我们在这里常说的一件事是，这一切都始于你，格雷格，真的。
life and we had all grown to love this fictional romance and we wanted to celebrate this milestone together as a group. And so I saw like this mixture of, I mean, it's like I saw Dwight dancing down the aisle, but I also saw Rain dancing down the aisle. So for me, it was like even more impactful and emotional. It was so joyous. I mean, it really was shooting it was joyous, watching it. Yeah.
就像你打开了我们剧中的创意社区，你总是关心人们的想法并倾听我们，但每个人，无论他是谁。你都在那一刻和他们在一起，倾听他们，我只是觉得我们的剧总是因此而变得更好，因为你让我们感到受欢迎，成为过程的一部分。我们所有人。嗯，在那一点上，我觉得到第六季时，我们都知道这部剧是什么了。你知道我的意思吗？
I mean, that's kind of how the show was made, right? I mean, it wasn't like we went into it with one version of what it was supposed to be. Like the show really changed so much from everybody's creative input from whatever happened on set and then in the editing room and like it wasn't completely unusual for the table draft to not resemble the final cut very much. I mean, that was part of the process. It's true. It is, you know, something we say a lot here is that it all started with you, Greg, truly.
所以每个人都在参与并做出伟大的事情，当我看着那一集时，我只是想到这么多不同的贡献，你知道我的意思吗？比如表演和各种即兴发挥，舞蹈太棒了，你知道，那一集是由克莱尔·斯坎伦剪辑的，她后来成为了Netflix的一位伟大的浪漫喜剧导演，你知道，那个结尾图像的选择是她的功劳。她想出了把它放在哪里，交叉剪辑非常有价值，甚至吉姆关于他要问她计划B的那段谈话。
Like you just opened up this creative community on our show and you always cared about what people thought and listened to us and but everybody, it didn't matter who it was. You were there in the moment with them, hearing them and I just feel like our show always, always was better for it because you made us feel welcome to be part of the process. All of us. Well, by that, I think I feel like by that time, by season six, we all knew what the show was. Do you know what I mean?
就像我记得，那是丹尼·春写的，你知道，有来自这么多不同人的不同片段。看到每个人的贡献很有趣。我笑了，然后也哭了，我和伊莎贝尔一起看了。她非常喜欢它，说到这个，我不知道你是否还记得，我的女儿是花童。是的。那超级有趣，我把整部电影都存在某个地方，因为我带了我的，你知道，
So everybody was participating and hitting great things and when I look at that episode, I just think about like so many different contributions, do you know what I mean? Like from the performances and various ad libs and the dancing was awesome and you know, that was, that one was edited by Claire Scanlon, you know, who went on to be a great romantic comedy director now at Netflix and, you know, the choice of that ending image of like that was her. She figured out where to put that in and the intercutting was so valuable and even that talking head from Jim about he was going to ask her like the plan B thing.
我的摄像机去录东西，我不知道你是否还记得这个时刻，但我把它存在某个家庭电影里，埃德拿出了他的班卓琴，克里德在弹吉他，每个人都坐在那里等着重新打光，每个人都只是，这在拍摄期间是最好的氛围。太棒了。是的。教堂有一个侧面的户外露台，如果你愿意的话，我们在那里放了椅子，有一个小场地，像个庭院，你的女儿夏洛特在跑
Like I remember, oh, that was Danny Chun, he wrote that and you know, there's like different pieces came in from so many different people. It's, it's fun to see everybody's contributions. It was, I laughed and then also cried and I watched it with Isabel. She loved it so much and speaking of that, I don't know if you remember this, but I had, my daughter was the, was the, the flower girl. Yes. That was super fun and I have the whole movie somewhere because I, I brought my, you know,
来跑去，伊莎贝尔也来了，她在我的肩膀上，我们在玩，埃德在唱歌，克里德也在，这太棒了。那天我还给珍娜拍了一张漂亮的照片。她穿着怀孕的婚纱回头看着我，我当时想，我必须捕捉到这一刻。是的。好的，格雷格，在这个非常浪漫的剧集结尾，很明显迈克尔
my camcorder to, to tape stuff and I don't know if you remember this moment, but I have it on a home movie somewhere where Ed took out his banjo and Creed was playing the guitar and everybody was sitting around waiting for it to be relit and everybody was just sort of, it just, it was the best vibe during the shooting. It was so great. Yeah. And the church had this sort of side outdoor patio, if you will, and we had chairs out there and there was a little field, like a courtyard and, and your daughter was running
要和帕姆的妈妈在一起了，我们知道那会走向何方。它会走向那场闻名世界的耳光。但我的意思是，告诉我们你们是如何构思这个故事的。事情就是这样运作的，对吧，每一季都会以关于重大里程碑的模糊想法开始，比如我们会知道帕姆和吉姆这一季应该结婚，因为他们到了那个阶段，而且，你知道，你知道，所有这些不同的事情，你知道，你对你要去哪里有一个模糊的想法。然后有大量的生成，然后你会把所有这些
around Charlotte and, and Isabel had come and she was on my shoulders and we were playing and Ed was singing and Creed and it was just so great. I took a beautiful picture of Jenna that day too. She looked over her shoulder at me and her pregnant wedding dress and I was like, I have to capture this. Yeah. All right. So Greg, at the end of this very romantic episode, it becomes very clear that Michael
有趣的卡片放在板上，你知道，你可以看到它们，你会想，是的，迈克尔和帕姆的妈妈约会有很多奇怪冲突和有趣尴尬的潜力。所以那是一张卡片，你知道，这感觉像是这个大剧集结尾的一个很好的前瞻，我们知道很多人会看，而且它在剧集结尾给了迈克尔一点点成功，以一种有趣的方式，因为他在剧集中表现得太差了。我觉得这太完美了，因为你知道在你参加过的每一场婚礼上，都有
is going to hook up with Pam's mom and we know where that's going to go. It's going to go toward the slap herd around the world. But I mean, what, tell us about how you guys conceived of this story. The way things worked, right, is every season would begin with a vague idea of big milestones like we would know Pam and Jim ought to get married this season because they're at that stage and, you know, you know, all these different things where, you know, you have a vague idea of where you're going. And then there is this, this enormous amount of generating and then you'd have all these
那种你事后听说的随机勾搭。是的。这说得通，但随后有那个随机的，我当时想，天哪，迈克尔和帕姆的妈妈。但还有帕姆的朋友和德怀特，帕姆在婚礼当天发生了什么？为什么她所有的朋友和家人都在和她的同事勾搭？是的。嗯，那就是德怀特和迈克尔的故事，变成了迈克尔的故事
funny things on the cards and, you know, you could see them and you'd be like, yeah, well Michael dating Pam's mom has potential for like a lot of weird conflict and, you know, funny awkwardness and everything. And so that was a card, you know, it just felt like a good throw forward at the end of this big episode that we knew a lot of people would be watching and, and it gave Michael a little bit of success at the end of the episode in a funny way because he struck out so much during the episode. I thought it was so perfect because you know at every wedding you've ever been to, there's
的想法是，他们，你知道，迈克尔特别是一个真正认为帕姆是一个特别的人的人。所以他能去参加她的婚礼，那里一定有所有这些特别的人。比如我曾经有一个《宋飞正传》的剧集，从未制作过，但我被雇去写它。那一集是乔治惊吓了一位在公共电话亭打电话的非常美丽的女人，她跑开了。他戴着滑雪面罩，因为天气太冷了，他吓坏了她，她跑开了，留下了她的活页本。
that rando hookup that you hear about after the fact. Yeah. And that makes sense, but then there's that random one and I was like, oh my God, Michael and Pam's mom. But also Pam's friend and Dwight, what has happened to Pam on her wedding day? Why are all of her friends and family hooking up with her coworkers? Yeah. Well, that was the whole like Dwight Michael story that became the home by Michael story
他有一个想法，他要给活页本里的每个人打电话，试图找出这个女人是谁，这样他就可以把活页本还给她。但她的朋友们也非常漂亮。他开始说，这就像圣杯。我有活页本，你知道，一个美女的黑皮书，这里面的人都很漂亮。所以我得用它来尝试和每个人约会。所以我认为这就是迈克尔的想法，就像，哦，在帕姆的婚礼上，他们都会很棒。他们都会是帕姆的，帕姆的各种版本。所以这是我们今年真正要得分的地方。是的。大奖。是的。所以他最终和帕姆的妈妈在一起了。所以。
was the idea that they, you know, Michael especially is somebody who really thinks Pam is a special person. So for him to get to go to her wedding, like there must be all these special people there. Like I had a Seinfeld episode once that never got produced, but I was hired to write it. The episode was George startles a very beautiful woman who's making a phone call at a public pay phone and she runs off. He's wearing a ski mask because it's freezing and he freaks her out and she runs off and she leaves behind her filo facts.
我知道，我的意思是，当你说明迈克尔要和帕姆的妈妈约会时，你会想，天哪，但随后他们在一起的场景。他们两个，剧本和表演，就像我当时想的，哦，他们有点甜。我有那一刻，我支持他们。我不敢相信杏子果皮的事情。那太搞笑了。我忘了那个。哦，格雷格，这太有趣了。
And he has this idea that he's going to call everybody in the filo facts and try and find out who this woman is so he can get her her filo facts back. But all of her friends are very beautiful too. And he, he starts to say, this is, this is like the holy grail. I have the filo facts, you know, the black book of a beautiful woman, they're all beautiful in here. And so I got to use it to try and set up dates with everybody. But so I think that was Michael's idea was like, oh, at Pam's wedding, they're all going
我们错过了什么吗？还有什么你想告诉我们关于这一集的吗？天哪，我不知道。我只是在享受一些时刻，喜剧时刻，比如凯文的头发。当他戴着假发进来时，我当时想，天哪，这就像奥利弗·哈迪。他只是进来坐下，还有和奥斯卡的那个副线。天哪。
to be great. They're all going to be Pam's, the very various versions of Pam's. So this is where we're going to really score for the whole year. Yeah. Jackpot. Yeah. And so then he ends up with Pam's mom. So.
我不知道。那一集里有太多有趣的事情了。是的。奥斯卡对帕姆的姐姐认为他们是一对感到非常震惊。是的。是的。他想要一个道歉。他说，你在开玩笑吗？
And I know it's like, I mean, when you say Michael's going to date Pam's mom and you're like, oh my God, but then there's scenes together. The two of them and the writing and the performance, like I was like, oh, they're kind of sweet. I had the moment where I was rooting for them. I couldn't believe the thing with the apricot fruit leather. That was hilarious. I had forgotten that. Oh, Greg, this has been so fun.
是的。那太棒了。我喜欢那个家伙。我忘了那个家伙了。你还记得那个扮演酒店经理的家伙吗，他看起来像真人版的“垂头丧气狗”？是的。我忘了他了。
Is there anything we missed? Anything else you want to tell us about this episode? Gosh, I don't know. I was just enjoying some of the moments, the comedy moments, like Kevin's hair. And just when he comes in with his toupee on, I was just like, oh God, it's like Oliver Hardy. And he just comes in and sits down and that whole subplot with Oscar. Oh my God.
他太棒了。但关于那次拍摄有太多美好的回忆。我不知道。那就像，我觉得我们作为一部剧正处于巅峰时期，这太有趣了，而且太浪漫了。我没能去尼亚加拉。那听起来是一次很棒的拍摄。你知道，我喜欢看到所有关于它的镜头，但这一定很有趣，珍。
I don't know. There were so many fun things in that episode. Yes. With Oscar so horrified that Pam's sister thinks that there are a couple. Yeah. Yeah. He wants an apology. He's like, are you kidding me?
是的。那是第一次，也是唯一一次我离开洛杉矶去拍摄《办公室》。这真的很有趣。我们就像一个小团体，你知道，能到外面的世界去真的很酷，因为我们总是在一个泡沫里拍摄，小镇对我们的到来感到非常兴奋。人们会跟着我们。
Yeah. That was great. I love the guy. I forgot about the guy. Do you remember the guy who plays the hotel manager who served like a human version of Droopy Dog? Yes. I forgot about him.
他们会在酒店外等候，他们会成群结队地跟着我们去我们拍摄的所有不同地方，完全尊重。但我们在那里是一个奇观。能感受到这一点真是一次旅行，你知道，因为你真的，尤其是我们的剧，但任何剧你真的在一个泡沫里制作它，你得不到那种即时的观众反应。人们太兴奋了。约翰和我，我记得我们在去一个地点的车上向人们挥手。
He's terrific. But there are so many good memories of that shoot. I don't know. That was like, I feel like we were really in our prime as a show and it was just so fun and it was so romantic. And I didn't get to go to Niagara. That sounded like a great shoot. You know, I loved seeing all the footage from that, but that must have been fun, Jen.
然后那张照片第二天就登上了他们当地报纸的头版。太疯狂了。我把它送到我的酒店房间，我当时想，天哪，那是昨天发生的。我记得那个。是的。那很酷。对我来说疯狂的是，珍娜说当他们在船上时，她告诉我
Yeah. Would you? That was the first time I, and only time that I left Los Angeles to shoot the office. And it was really fun. It was just like, it was such a small group of us, you know, and it was really cool to be out in the world because we always filmed in such a bubble and the town was so excited we were there. And people would just follow us.
他们不得不做一个公告。珍娜和约翰，他们说，嘿，伙计们，请不要分享任何这些，因为她穿着婚纱，你知道？你能，我们能集体，因为你们和别人在船上。对吧。不是全是临时演员，对吧？有，还是他们？不。
They would wait outside the hotel and they would like in a group follow us to all the different places we were shooting, completely respectful. But it was, it was a spectacle that we were there. And it was just such a trip to feel that, you know, because you really, especially our show, but any show you really make it in a bubble, you don't get that kind of immediate audience response. And people were just so excited. John and I, I remember we like waved at people on our way getting into a car to go to a location.
我们只被允许租下船的前部。船的其余部分挤满了付费乘客。所以我们每次旅行，我们都会做一个公告并合影，但请人们在剧集播出前保密，并保守我们的共同秘密。他们做到了。它没有泄露出去。甚至报纸也刊登了我们在那里，但没有说为什么。
And then that picture ended up on like the front page of their local newspaper the next day. It was so crazy. I got it delivered to my hotel room and I was like, oh my gosh, that happened yesterday. I remember that. Yeah. That's cool. What's wild to me is that Jenna said when they were on the boat, she was telling me that
他们没有说我们在拍摄婚礼剧集。他们只是说《办公室》在城里为即将到来的一集拍摄东西。我们不可能在Instagram的世界里做到这一点。不。不。我的意思是。不。那太神奇了。
they had to make an announcement. And Jenna and John, they were like, hey, you guys, please don't share any of this because she's in a wedding dress, you know? And can you, can we just all collectively, because you were on the boat with other people. Right. There wasn't all extras, right? There was, or were they? No.
这真的很酷。我的意思是，这感觉很特别。这真的很酷。当你们回来并听到所有故事时，我太嫉妒了。但有50集，我当时想，我没法去拍那部分。嗯，我们只在那里待了大约36小时。我的意思是，就像，我们降落，我们睡着了，我们拍了一天，我们睡着了，我们起床并上了飞机。
We were only allowed to rent out the front of the boat. And the rest of the boat was filled with paying customers. And so every trip that we took, we would make an announcement and pose for a photo, but ask people to please keep it private until the episode aired and keep our collective secret. And they did. It did not get out. Even the newspaper printed that we were there, but didn't say why.
是的。我喜欢尼亚加拉大瀑布那些俗气东西的镜头，那也在那里。那很酷。是的。我真的很喜欢那个，因为我从来没去过，而且，你知道，吉姆有那段关于尼亚加拉大瀑布的谈话，我很高兴它在里面，因为我没有参考点，你知道？是的。
They didn't say we were shooting a wedding episode. They just said the office is in town to shoot something for an upcoming episode. We could not have done this in the world of Instagram. No. No. I mean. No. That's amazing.
嗯，那是我一直在做的关于尼亚加拉大瀑布研究的根源。在，你知道，我终于在几年后看到了它，但那是在那一集之后，我以前从未去过。你知道，对我来说，看到瀑布美得令人窒息。我当时想，哦，等等，我必须说台词。等等，我的台词是什么？是的。我不，我们，我想我们，提到台词很有趣，因为我不
It was really cool. I mean, it felt special. It was really cool. I was so jealous when you guys came back and heard all the stories. But with the 50 episodes, I was like, there's no way I can go to do that part. Well, we were only there for like 36 hours. I mean, it was like, we landed, we fell asleep, we shot for a day, we fell asleep, we got up and got on a plane.
觉得我们最终用了任何台词。它在剪辑在一起的方式中全是B-roll，对吧？没错。没错。但我们确实有誓言，但我们，你最终没有听到它们。它全在歌声下。是的。它可能是一个很好的选择，因为瀑布非常非常吵。
Yeah. I liked the footage of the Durious Kitchy Things in Niagara Falls that was also there. That was cool. Yeah. I really liked that because I've never been and I, you know, Jim has that talking head about Niagara Falls and I was so glad that was in there because I didn't have a point of reference, you know? Yeah.
是的。所以我想象我的麦克风就像，嗯，还有，你每次都湿透了，对吧？每次拍摄你都必须，你必须重做头发之类的。是的。天哪。就像，我太想去了，我真的想去。我和你一起去。你真的会吗？
Well, that was the root of all the research that I had been doing about Niagara Falls. After, you know, I finally got to see it like a couple of years later, but it was after the episode I'd never been before. You know, for me, it was like, it was breathtakingly beautiful to see the falls. And I was like, oh, wait, I have to say lines. Wait, what are my lines? Yeah. I don't, we're, I think we, that's funny that you're mentioning lines because I don't
当然。这太酷了。我会去，然后我说，电话在哪里？我可以集中注意力。格雷格，和我们一起去。我们去瀑布吧。是的。我实际上去了，我在多伦多拍东西，我做了一次旅行。
feel like we ended up using any lines. It was all sort of B-roll in the way it got cut together, right? That's right. That's right. But we did have vows that we were saying, but we, you don't end up hearing them. It was all under the song. Yeah. It may, it was probably a good choice because the falls are very, very loud.
就像如果你在多伦多，去那里超级容易。哦，从加拿大那边？是的。是的。嗯，你们应该成为特别的“办公室女士”。公路旅行。公路旅行。我们有很多想去的地方。
Yeah. So I imagined that my microphone was like, well, also like you got wet each time, right? Each take you had to, you had to redo your hair and stuff. Yeah. Oh my God. It was like, I so want to go like, I really want to go. I'll go with you. Will you really?
好的，格雷格。格雷格加入了。写下来。格雷格，这太美妙了。非常感谢。是的。有机会再次观看它并和你们一起回忆它真是太有趣了。嗯，请随时来。
Of course. It was so cool. I'll go and then I said, where is the phone? I can concentrate. Greg, come with us. Let's go to the falls. Yeah. I went actually, I was shooting something in Toronto and I took a trip.
当然。那太酷了。我去了，然后我说，电话在哪？我可以集中注意力。格雷格，跟我们一起去吧。我们去瀑布吧。是的。其实我当时在多伦多拍东西，就顺便去了一趟。
Like if you're ever in Toronto, it's super easy to get there. Oh, from the Canadian side? Yeah. Yeah. Well, you guys should be special office lady. Road trip. Road trip. We have so many places we want to go.
如果你去多伦多的话，去那里超级方便。哦，从加拿大那边吗？是的。好吧，你们应该成为特别办公室女士。公路旅行。公路旅行。我们有太多想去的地方了。
All right, Greg. Greg's in. Writing them down. Greg, this was so wonderful. Thank you so much. Yeah. It was so fun to get a chance to watch it all again and remember it again with you guys. Well, please come on any time.
好吧，格雷格。格雷格加入了。正在记下来。格雷格，这真是太棒了。非常感谢。是的。有机会再看一遍并和你们一起重温这些记忆真是太有趣了。好的，随时欢迎再来。
We would love to have you. Oh, it's my pleasure. Do you have anything that is coming out or anything you want to give a plug to? Well, actually, this is a big couple of months for me. I have a reality show that I did with my daughter, Hailey, that's coming out on HBO Max called My Mom or Your Dad. You guys should check that out. It's a reality show.
我们非常欢迎你来。哦，这是我的荣幸。你最近有什么新作品要推出，或者有什么想宣传的吗？嗯，其实这几个月对我来说很重要。我和女儿海莉一起做了一档真人秀，即将在HBO Max上线，名字叫《我妈还是你爸》（My Mom or Your Dad）。你们一定要去看看。这是一档真人秀节目。
I saw a clip of it and it tell us a little bit about it because it looks really, really cool. Okay. Yeah. So the idea is that people in their fifties who are single parents are nominated by their kids who are in their twenties to go and live in a house together like eight or 10 of them so that they can have a second chance at finding love. And then the kids, what they don't know is that the kids are living in a house down the
我看了其中的片段，能给我们介绍一下吗？因为它看起来真的很棒。好的。嗯，这个节目的构思是，让一群五十多岁、单身的父母，由他们二十多岁的孩子提名，去住进一栋房子里，大概有八到十个人，让他们有机会寻找第二次爱情。然后，孩子们，他们不知道的是，孩子们住在街对面的一栋房子里，
street and watching everything, all the feed on like a bunch of TVs and the kids are competing for the ability to influence what's happening in the parents' house. So they can like put, match people up and make the dates go better if they sacrifice things or they can screw up dates if they don't like who the parent is dating. Oh my gosh. Yeah. How many episodes are there? Eight.
盯着所有的一切，通过一堆电视屏幕看着所有的直播画面，孩子们在竞争，看谁能影响父母那栋房子里发生的事情。所以他们可以撮合别人，如果他们做出牺牲，就能让约会变得更顺利，或者如果他们不喜欢父母约会的对象，也可以搞砸约会。天哪。是啊。一共有多少集？八集。
Oh my gosh. So you can binge that so fast. Yeah. And then Space Force season two is going to come out in like a week or so. So that's something that's pretty cool. So that's Steve and a bunch of fun, you know, we'll see who else was on the office. Tim Meadows is guest starring this year. Oh my gosh.
天哪。那你很快就能刷完了。是啊。然后《太空部队》（Space Force）第二季大概一周左右就会上线。所以那也很酷。那是史蒂夫和一群有趣的人，你知道，我们还会看到还有谁在《办公室》里。蒂姆·梅多斯今年会客串。天哪。
I love Tim Meadows. Yeah. And then in March, the second season of Upload comes out, which is that show that I do for Amazon. Oh my gosh. And then again, you were like double show running, triple show running again. This is your specialty. This was the last, I mean, the last time was season six in the office in parks.
我喜欢蒂姆·梅多斯。是啊。然后在三月，《上传》（Upload）第二季会出来，就是我为亚马逊制作的那部剧。天哪。而且你又在同时担任两部、三部剧的制片人。这是你的专长。这是上一次，我是说，上一次是《办公室》第六季和《公园与游憩》。
And then I broke me for several years and then this time was, uh, was during the pandemic. Yeah. I had another double up, triple up, triple up. So like when, when you go to pitch a show and then they're like, we want to buy it, they're like, great, but hold on, I have to sell a second show first because I only like to do two to three at a time in a bundle. Well, you know what happens? It's like you never know what's going to get picked up, right?
然后那几年把我累坏了，这次是在疫情期间。是啊。我又经历了一次双重、三重、三重叠加。所以，当你去推销一部剧，他们说，我们想买，他们会说，太棒了，但等等，我得先卖掉第二部剧，因为我一次只喜欢打包做两到三部。嗯，你知道会发生什么吗？就像你永远不知道哪部剧会被选中，对吧？
When you're like, I'm like an independent producer. So I'm out there, flogging my wares and everything and trying to make things happen. And then, you know, you'll go for a period of time with nothing happening and then suddenly everything will hit at the same time and you can't really control it, but that's what happened. Well, it's all good stuff, Greg. We're so excited. So you guys be sure to check out my mom, your dad on HBO max, space force on Netflix and
当你像我一样是个独立制片人时。所以我一直在外面兜售我的作品，试图让事情发生。然后，你知道，你会经历一段时间什么都没发生，然后突然间所有事情都同时爆发了，你真的无法控制，但事情就是这样发生的。嗯，这都是好东西，格雷格。我们太兴奋了。所以你们一定要去HBO Max上看《我妈还是你爸》，在Netflix上看《太空部队》，还有
upload on Amazon. You guys, Greg Daniels amazing. We love you so much, Greg. Well, thanks so much. This is so fun. And all the other office ladies episodes are also great. Thank you. And we'll go into Niagara.
在亚马逊上看《上传》。你们这些家伙，格雷格·丹尼尔斯太棒了。我们非常爱你，格雷格。嗯，太感谢了。这太有趣了。所有其他的《办公室女士》剧集也很棒。谢谢。我们要进入尼亚加拉篇了。
Yes. We'll see you in Niagara, Greg. Yep. I'm there. I love you. Okay. Love you too. See you later.
是的。我们在尼亚加拉见，格雷格。好的。我到了。我爱你。好的。我也爱你。回头见。
Love you. Bye. Love him. Love, Greg. We could not be more grateful that he came on our podcast to talk to us about this episode. I know. What a great way to kick it off. Well, we have tons to cover, Jenna.
爱你。再见。爱他。爱格雷格。他能来我们的播客谈论这一集，我们感激不尽。我知道。这真是一个完美的开场。嗯，我们有很多内容要讲，珍娜。
I think you need to hit us with a summary. I will give you a summary of what we're breaking down today, which is Niagara part one. The staff of Dunder Mifflin head to Niagara Falls for Jim and Pam's wedding with strict instructions not to mention Pam's pregnancy to her conservative me maw Dwight and Michael endeavor to pick up women and Andy injures his scrotum. That's what we'll be discussing today. Not a sentence. I thought you'd say this morning.
我想你需要给我们一个总结。我会给你一个我们今天要拆解的内容总结，也就是《尼亚加拉》第一部分。邓德·米夫林的员工前往尼亚加拉大瀑布参加吉姆和帕姆的婚礼，并被严厉指示不要向帕姆保守的曾祖母提及帕姆怀孕的事。德怀特和迈克尔努力去搭讪女性，而安迪伤到了他的阴囊。这就是我们今天要讨论的内容。这不是我今早想说的句子。
I know. Injured scrotum. Injured scrotum. Features heavily in this episode. Well, a lot has been said about this episode, Jenna. We're going to share as much of it as we can. There's also two DVD commentaries for this. One is with Paul Feig and Greg Daniels.
我知道。受伤的阴囊。受伤的阴囊。在这一集中占了很大篇幅。嗯，关于这一集已经说了很多了，珍娜。我们要尽可能多地分享。这一集还有两段DVD评论音轨。一个是保罗·费格和格雷格·丹尼尔斯的。
The other features are producer Randy Cordray, our first assistant director, Kelly Cantley, Mary Wall from our production staff, Claire Scanlon, our editor, Michael Gallenberg, our production designer, and Veta Samarne, our script supervisor. These are fantastic commentaries. If you're a fan of the commentary, this DVD is for you. Wow. I know we've said this was a big episode. We're going to keep saying it, you guys, but it really was.
另一个特色嘉宾是制片人兰迪·科德雷、我们的第一副导演凯利·坎特利、来自制作组的玛丽·沃尔、剪辑师克莱尔·斯坎伦、美术指导迈克尔·加伦伯格，以及剧本主管维塔·萨马内。这些评论非常精彩。如果你是评论音轨的粉丝，这张DVD就是为你准备的。哇。我知道我们说过这是一集大制作。我们要一直说下去，伙计们，但它确实是。
Claire Scanlon, our editor, said her original cut came in at 64 minutes, and she had to cut it down to 42 minutes and 30 seconds. She said it was actually painful to cut that much, and there are so many awesome deleted storylines. I'm going to share some of those with you. Well, I can't wait, you know, this episode opens with a lot of puking. So much. So much puking.
我们的剪辑师克莱尔·斯坎伦说，她最初的剪辑版本长达64分钟，她不得不把它剪到42分30秒。她说剪掉这么多内容其实很痛苦，而且有太多很棒的被删减的故事情节。我会和你们分享其中一些。嗯，我等不及了，你知道，这一集是以大量的呕吐开场的。太多了。太多的呕吐了。
We talked a little bit about it with Greg. We have more to say. Basically we see Pam, she's standing next to Jim, and she is asking her fellow office mates if they could just help her out. Her stomach is really sensitive because she's pregnant, and like maybe Phyllis could use like a less perfumey soap, maybe they could eat less stinky lunches. This does not go over well. Oh no, people are not happy about it.
我们和格雷格聊了一点。我们还有更多要说的。基本上我们看到帕姆，她站在吉姆旁边，她在问她的同事们能不能帮帮她。她的胃很敏感，因为她怀孕了，也许菲利斯可以用一种没那么香的肥皂，也许他们可以少吃点味道重的午餐。这并没有得到很好的回应。哦不，大家对此并不高兴。
They want to live their life at their office and not worry about Pam's pregnancy. Exactly. They actually revolt, and Dwight purposely starts eating a hard-boiled egg at his desk pod with Pam. Stinky. Stinky. Yeah. She looks him right in the eye and pukes in her trash can.
他们想在办公室过自己的生活，不想担心帕姆的怀孕。没错。他们实际上反抗了，德怀特故意开始在他的办公桌旁吃一个水煮蛋，就在帕姆旁边。臭。臭。是啊。她直视他的眼睛，然后吐在垃圾桶里。
That was disgusting. Andy then has a talking head, and he says watching people get sick always makes him sick, and frankly, so does talking about it, and then he starts to gag. This sets off the whole bullpen. Well I have some fun behind the scenes info about this cold open. First off, Greg and Mindy supposedly wrote this cold open together on a Sunday morning in a diner. I just find it interesting that they were having a delicious Sunday brunch while they
那太恶心了。安迪随后有一个采访镜头，他说看别人恶心总是让他自己也恶心，坦白说，谈论这件事也一样，然后他开始干呕。这引发了整个办公室的连锁反应。嗯，关于这个冷开场，我有一些有趣的幕后信息。首先，格雷格和敏迪据说是周日早上在一家餐馆一起写了这个冷开场。我只是觉得很有趣，他们在享用美味的周日早午餐时，却
wrote about vomiting. I guess Greg is the one who came up with Dwight's three-ounce fetus line, and then Mindy said in an interview with OfficeTelly.com that we spent a very long time shooting this cold open because they kept stopping to have discussions about how much vomit should each person vomit. Should Ellie vomit on the floor? Should she vomit in a cup? How can we best show Angela's vomit coming through her fingers? There was so much vomit detail work.
写着关于呕吐的内容。我想格雷格是那个想出德怀特“三盎司胎儿”台词的人，然后敏迪在接受OfficeTelly.com采访时说，我们花了很多时间拍摄这个冷开场，因为他们一直在停下来讨论每个人应该吐多少。艾莉应该吐在地板上吗？她应该吐在杯子里吗？我们怎样才能最好地展示安吉拉的呕吐物从指缝中流出？有太多的呕吐细节工作了。
I want you to know Paul Feig was delighted that I was going to puke through my hand. That was like, we had to make sure we got it through my fingers. Well, it was in the script that way. I know. It says that you try to cover your mouth and the vomit spews through your fingers. Yeah. Craziness. Well, I also got a fan question from Faith B. in Berryville, Virginia, who said, I was
我想让你知道，保罗·费格很高兴我能从手缝中吐出来。那就像是，我们必须确保它是从我的指缝中流出来的。嗯，剧本里就是这么写的。我知道。上面写着你试图捂住嘴，然后呕吐物从你的指缝中喷涌而出。是啊。疯狂。嗯，我还收到了来自弗吉尼亚州贝里维尔的费丝·B的粉丝提问，她说，我
wondering what was used for the vomit in the cold open of Niagara Part 1. Well, Randy Cordray, our line producer, shared that our prop department actually had to create several different types of vomit custom-made for each character. You know, you need a different thing to spew through the fingers than you do to go in the trash can. Also in theory, all of these different people had had different meals that day. Yes. So, it was puke would look the same.
想知道《尼亚加拉》第一部分冷开场里的呕吐物是用什么做的。嗯，我们的执行制片人兰迪·科德雷分享说，我们的道具部门实际上必须为每个角色定制几种不同类型的呕吐物。你知道，从指缝中喷出的东西和吐在垃圾桶里的东西需要不同的质感。而且理论上，所有这些不同的人那天吃了不同的饭菜。是的。所以，呕吐物看起来不会是一样的。
Yes. So, I guess it was mostly soup, different kinds of soup, but sometimes they put soggy bits of bread in it if they needed it to be a little chunkier. I can tell you it was disgusting and pretending to puke wasn't that hard. Faith shared that there was extra vomit footage that didn't make it in. It's not in the deleted scenes on the DVD, but apparently Jim vomited, too. But one thing they all could agree on in the editing room was that they wanted to end on Creed eating noodles in the midst of everyone being sick around him.
是的。所以，我想大部分是汤，不同种类的汤，但有时如果需要更浓稠一点，他们会放一些湿透的面包屑。我可以告诉你，那很恶心，假装呕吐并不难。费丝分享说，还有一些没用上的额外呕吐镜头。DVD的删减片段里没有，但显然吉姆也吐了。但剪辑室里他们都能达成一致的一点是，他们想以克里德在周围人都在呕吐的情况下吃面条作为结尾。
Well, if you can believe it, the creation of this cold open didn't end there. They then had to send it to post-production where they added and enhanced our puking sounds. Yeah. To capture all of that, plus everything they were going to need for Niagara Part 1, Greg shared that they used the shorter opening title sequence because it saved us nine seconds and we needed every single one of those. Well, I think we should get into this episode. Let's do it.
嗯，如果你敢相信的话，这个冷开场的创作并没有到此结束。他们随后不得不把它送到后期制作，在那里他们添加并增强了我们的呕吐声。是啊。为了捕捉所有这些，加上他们为《尼亚加拉》第一部分所需的一切，格雷格分享说，他们使用了较短的片头序列，因为它节省了九秒钟，而我们每一秒都需要。嗯，我觉得我们应该进入这一集了。开始吧。
Well, let's start off right away with a deleted scene, Jenna. Oh! This episode would have started with Pam doing a wedding vlog at home. As her and Jim got ready, it's so adorable, we have to hear it. Hello, world. This is Pam Beasley, and this is the latest installment of my wedding video diary. This afternoon, my fiance Jim and I are going to Niagara Falls to get married after a half day of work.
嗯，让我们直接从一个删减片段开始吧，珍娜。哦！这一集本应以帕姆在家录制婚礼视频博客开始。当她和吉姆准备好时，太可爱了，我们必须听听。你好，世界。我是帕姆·比斯利，这是我婚礼视频日记的最新一期。今天下午，我的未婚夫吉姆和我将在半天工作后去尼亚加拉大瀑布结婚。
Woohoo! I'm getting my marriage on! Sorry, I'm just really excited. Okay, so let's see. Last time I talked about the difficulties of throwing a wedding on a budget, specifically flower arrangements. My solution? Paper flowers.
呜呼！我要去结婚了！抱歉，我只是太兴奋了。好吧，让我们看看。上次我谈到了预算内举办婚礼的困难，特别是花艺布置。我的解决方案？纸花。
I made these using a regular cardstock that I found in the warehouse. Can you believe they were going to just throw that away? Hey, babe. You got to let me know when you're doing that. Okay, so I totally remember shooting these. What is happening in the background there is that at the end of her vlog, Jim walks out of the bathroom in his underwear brushing his teeth, and then he has to turn around and go back to the bathroom.
我用我在仓库里找到的普通卡纸做的。你能相信他们本来打算直接扔掉吗？嘿，宝贝。你做那个的时候得告诉我。好的，所以我完全记得拍摄这些片段。背景里发生的事情是，在她的视频博客结束时，吉姆穿着内衣刷着牙从浴室走出来，然后他不得不转身回到浴室。
Yeah, he didn't know she was vlogging. They built a little bedroom for Jim and Pam back behind where we would usually have lunch, a little bit off of our set, and we filmed these little vlogs in that little room. Well, they're super cute. I loved them. Aw. Well, this episode actually gets started with Pam and Jim arriving to work in their cute little casual clothes, and Michael is showing them how he has decorated his car for their
是啊，他不知道她在录视频博客。他们在我们通常吃午饭的地方后面为吉姆和帕姆搭建了一个小卧室，离我们的片场有点远，我们在那个小房间里拍摄了这些小视频博客。嗯，它们超级可爱。我很喜欢。噢。嗯，这一集实际上是从帕姆和吉姆穿着可爱的休闲装到达办公室开始的，迈克尔正在向他们展示他为他们的
wedding. His car. His car is decorated and has cans behind it. Yes. Instead of saying just married on the back windshield, he wrote going to a wedding. Well, Jim and Pam are going to ask everyone to come in the conference room because they want to give them a list of dos and don'ts for the wedding. Already on the dry erase board under the don'ts is make a big scene, cry, talk to our family,
婚礼装饰了他的车。他的车。他的车装饰好了，后面还拖着罐子。是的。后挡风玻璃上写的不是“刚结婚”，而是“去参加婚礼”。嗯，吉姆和帕姆要让大家到会议室来，因为他们想给他们一份婚礼的注意事项清单。白板上“不要做”的下面已经写着：大闹一场、哭泣、和我们的家人说话、
bash, very busy. Under the dos, it's have a good time. Dance when it is appropriate and eat dinner. Right away, there's a heated debate because Kevin, I guess, really wanted to bring fire crackers. Yeah. So Jim has to put that under the don't column. And now here comes the big secret.
猛冲、非常忙碌。在“要做”的下面，是玩得开心。在适当的时候跳舞，吃晚饭。立刻就发生了一场激烈的辩论，因为凯文，我想，真的很想带鞭炮。是啊。所以吉姆不得不把它放在“不要做”那一栏。现在大秘密来了。
They really need everyone to not say it with them. Do not say Pam is pregnant. Don't do it. Don't say it. Pam's memaw doesn't know. Don't say it. Angela tells Pam she's lucky to have a grandmother. Jenna, this is one of my lines from the whole run of the show that gets quoted to me.
他们真的需要每个人都不要说出来。不要说帕姆怀孕了。别说。别说。帕姆的曾祖母不知道。别说。安吉拉告诉帕姆她很幸运有祖母。珍娜，这是我在整部剧里被引用最多的一句台词。
I'll be at Target and someone will say it to me. Well, you're lucky you have a grandmother. Some of us have to be our own grandmothers. Hmm. Yeah. I think Angela Martin and memaw would have hit it off. Oh, I so wish we could have had an Angela memaw scene. I know.
我在塔吉特百货，有人会对我这么说。嗯，你很幸运你有祖母。我们有些人必须成为自己的祖母。嗯。是啊。我觉得安吉拉·马丁和曾祖母会很合得来。哦，我真希望我们能有一场安吉拉和曾祖母的戏。我知道。
I think they seated side by side at the rehearsal dinner. No kidding. Oh my gosh. Well, Pam sort of retorts to Angela, you know, you don't have to come to the wedding and Michael's like, yes, she does and he leans forward and he pinches Angela. Jenna Steve really pinched me and that reaction is real. I really went out. Was that in the script or was that just like a little thing he did?
我觉得她们在彩排晚宴上坐在一起。不是开玩笑。天哪。嗯，帕姆对安吉拉反驳说，你知道，你不必来参加婚礼，迈克尔说，是的，她必须来，然后他向前倾身，掐了安吉拉。珍娜，史蒂夫真的掐了我，那个反应是真实的。我真的叫了出来。那是剧本里的，还是他随手做的小动作？
No, it was scripted that Michael pinches Angela under her arm, but you guys, when was the last time someone pinched you like under your arm? You have an honest reaction when it happens. Sure. Well, Michael and Dwight are hoping a lot happens at this wedding. Oh, yeah, they are. You know, in traditional Dwight and Michael style, there was a deleted scene, Jenna, where Dwight helps Michael pack.
不，剧本里写着迈克尔在安吉拉胳膊下掐她，但是伙计们，你们上次被人掐胳膊下是什么时候？当它发生时，你会有真实的反应。当然。嗯，迈克尔和德怀特希望在这个婚礼上发生很多事。哦，是的，他们希望。你知道，按照传统的德怀特和迈克尔风格，有一个删减片段，珍娜，德怀特帮迈克尔打包。
He goes over the list. You know how he does. Jenna, Michael shares that he's going to bring 78 items. You need to hear what these 78 items are. Oh my gosh. Deodorant toothpaste. Check. Did you bring condoms?
他检查清单。你知道他是怎么做的。珍娜，迈克尔分享说他要带78件物品。你需要听听这78件物品是什么。天哪。除臭剂、牙膏。检查。你带避孕套了吗？
Yes. Extra large. I brought 78 condoms. Oh man. 78, Jenna. Wow. Yeah. Hmm.
是的。超大号。我带了78个避孕套。天哪。78个，珍娜。哇。是啊。嗯。
Hmm. Dwight has made a list of every one of Jim and Pam's female family members and is going to break down their eligibility sort of. Well, if you count whether or not they've sold their bicycle online as a dating status. Yeah, exactly. You know, we got a fan question from Lauren Kay in Canada that I really appreciated. She said, I've never understood why everyone is always at the office before they go to leave somewhere, similar to like when Holly moved.
嗯。德怀特列出了吉姆和帕姆所有女性家人的名单，并打算分析她们的适婚程度。嗯，如果你把她们是否在网上卖过自行车算作约会状态的话。是啊，没错。你知道，我们收到了来自加拿大劳伦·K的一个粉丝提问，我非常欣赏。她说，我一直不明白为什么大家在去某个地方之前总是在办公室，就像霍莉搬走时那样。
Oh. Or before Pam went off to New York City. Why are Jim and Pam at the office the day before their wedding? Why is anyone there if they're just going to all leave in their casual clothes anyway? You know, Lauren, I don't know. I don't know what work they got done today. Perhaps Jim and Pam needed to come in to give everyone this speech. They saw the value in that one last speech to the group about me, Ma.
哦。或者在帕姆去纽约市之前。为什么吉姆和帕姆在婚礼前一天在办公室？如果他们无论如何都要穿着休闲装离开，为什么大家都在那里？你知道，劳伦，我不知道。我不知道他们今天完成了什么工作。也许吉姆和帕姆需要进来给每个人做这个演讲。他们看到了最后一次对大家关于曾祖母的演讲的价值。
But I agree. I think it's very funny. I'm just glad that Pam isn't driving to her wedding in a pencil skirt with pantyhose. Finally. Well, now everybody's going to kind of get in their little car pools. Michael and Dwight drive off in his decorated car. The cans are exploding. We got a fan question about that as well.
但我同意。我觉得这很有趣。我只是很高兴帕姆不用穿着铅笔裙和连裤袜去参加自己的婚礼。终于。嗯，现在每个人都要坐进他们的小拼车里了。迈克尔和德怀特开着他装饰过的车走了。罐子在爆炸。我们也收到了关于那个的粉丝提问。
John Dee from Lakewood, Colorado said, how did they do that? Was it real? Was it special effects? I mean, the cans were real. I guess this gag drove the crew crazy. Randy Kelly and Vada shared that it was just a very difficult thing to get. It seems like a small little moment, right, in the script, but it was very hard to capture. Yeah.
来自科罗拉多州莱克伍德的约翰·D说，他们是怎么做到的？是真的吗？是特效吗？我的意思是，罐子是真的。我想这个恶作剧让剧组快疯了。兰迪、凯利和维塔分享说，这只是一个非常难拍摄的东西。这看起来像是一个小小的瞬间，对吧，在剧本里，但很难捕捉到。是啊。
Randy told me that the writers were so tickled by this idea that these cans would explode. That Michael would put full cans. You guys, you're supposed to put empty cans, but Michael wouldn't think that through. They started by just dragging some full cans behind the car, hoping they would explode. They didn't. So they actually had to rig each can with a teeny tiny timed explosive charge to make them burst open. That happened.
兰迪告诉我，编剧们对这些罐子会爆炸的想法感到非常兴奋。迈克尔会放满罐子。伙计们，你们应该放空罐子，但迈克尔不会考虑那么多。他们开始只是在车后拖着一些满罐子，希望它们会爆炸。它们没有。所以他们实际上不得不给每个罐子安装一个微小的定时爆炸装置，让它们爆开。那发生了。
They burst open, but it wasn't all that exciting. So then they also had had like a sound effect to make it sort of louder. It was a very difficult little bit to pull off. But listen, this is a tradition, the thing of putting cans on the back of your car. Of course I looked it up. I guess that this goes all the way back to a French tradition, Angela. It's called, I'm going to pronounce this wrong, chivalry. And you're supposed to like create a bunch of noise after a couple is newly married.
它们爆开了，但并没有那么令人兴奋。所以他们还不得不加了音效让它听起来响一点。这是一个非常难完成的小片段。但听着，这是一个传统，在车后放罐子的事情。当然我查过了。我想这可以追溯到一个法国传统，安吉拉。它叫，我要读错这个词了，chivalry。你本应该在夫妻刚结婚后制造一堆噪音。
It was originally done where as the couple drove away, people would clang pots and pans and other noise makers, but then it eventually evolved into the can thing. But I thought you'd like this one, Angela, I guess in the Tudor period in England. I was going to say, how far back does this go? Yeah. There was this crazy tradition where as the couple would ride away in their carriage, guests would take off their shoes and throw it at the carriage. And if you hit the carriage, it meant good luck.
最初的做法是，当夫妻开车离开时，人们会敲打锅碗瓢盆和其他噪音制造器，但后来它演变成了罐子的事情。但我以为你会喜欢这个，安吉拉，我想在英国的都铎王朝时期。我正想说，这追溯到多久以前？是啊。有一个疯狂的传统，当夫妻坐马车离开时，客人们会脱下鞋子扔向马车。如果你击中了马车，就意味着好运。
So there have always been these little traditions of things to do as a couple is driving away. Throwing things at them, making noise, yeah. But that stunt was a nightmare. I have a driving stunt coming up. Yes, you do. You're going to run into Kevin. I fully nudged Brian Bob Gartner with that car, you guys. And it was a lot of fun.
所以一直都有这些小传统，在夫妻开车离开时做些事情。向他们扔东西，制造噪音，是啊。但那个特技简直是噩梦。我有一个驾驶特技要拍。是的，你有。你要撞到凯文。我完全用那辆车轻轻碰了布莱恩·鲍勃·加特纳，伙计们。这很有趣。
Listen, I was going 0.000 miles an hour, just a little tap, just a little tap. And we actually had a lot of fun doing that. I got really tickled. Everyone's on their way to Niagara now. You have all these different pairings and cars. It's really fun to see. You have Andy, Erin and Kelly. And you have Jim and Pam and Michael and Dwight.
听着，我当时以0.000英里的时速行驶，只是轻轻一碰，只是轻轻一碰。我们实际上玩得很开心。我被逗乐了。每个人现在都在去尼亚加拉的路上。你有所有这些不同的配对和车辆。看到这些真的很有趣。你有安迪、艾琳和凯利。还有吉姆和帕姆，以及迈克尔和德怀特。
Yes. There's that super sweet scene with Pam and Jim. And this is where we get, oh my gosh. I just loved it. Pam tells Jim that her aunt told her to take mental pictures of the high points of their wedding day because everything's going to go by so fast and they should try to remember it. And that's when Jim uses his fingers and pretends like he's taking a picture of Pam.
是的。帕姆和吉姆之间有那个超级甜蜜的场景。这就是我们得到，天哪。我太喜欢了。帕姆告诉吉姆，她阿姨告诉她要给婚礼当天的高光时刻拍“心理照片”，因为一切都会过得很快，他们应该试着记住它。就在那时，吉姆用手指假装他在给帕姆拍照。
This idea that Jim and Pam should take mental pictures was a pitch from Steve Carell. He had told Greg this story that he had a friend who would do this. And so Greg put it into the script for Jim and Pam. But when we read it, John and I, we didn't get it, like when we read the script. So Greg did that thing where he was like, Steve, come here, come here. Show these guys what you meant, the thing with the taking the mental pictures. So Steve kind of showed us. And then we were like, oh, we get it.
这个吉姆和帕姆应该拍心理照片的想法是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔提出的。他告诉格雷格这个故事，说他有一个朋友会这样做。所以格雷格把它写进了吉姆和帕姆的剧本里。但当我们读到它时，约翰和我，我们没明白，就像我们读剧本时那样。所以格雷格做了那种事，他就像，史蒂夫，过来，过来。给这些家伙展示一下你的意思，那个拍心理照片的事情。所以史蒂夫给我们展示了一下。然后我们就像，哦，我们明白了。
I just love that so much. And it goes to what Greg mentioned in the commentary, you guys, and also in our interview about how a lot of this episode was based off real life moments in people's lives. And this is one of them. You know, I also improvised a line in the scene, Angela. Which line? When Jim says, oh, you blinked, that was supposed to be the end. And I improvised the line, ah, we should have hired a professional to take our mental pictures.
我太喜欢那个了。这呼应了格雷格在评论音轨中提到的，伙计们，还有我们在采访中提到的，关于这一集有多少是基于人们生活中的真实时刻。这就是其中之一。你知道，我也在场景中即兴发挥了一句台词，安吉拉。哪一句？当吉姆说，哦，你眨眼了，那本应该是结尾。我即兴发挥了一句，啊，我们应该雇个专业人士来拍我们的心理照片。
Oh, I'm very proud of it. Very good. So Angela, you mentioned that Dwight and Michael are in the car together. And I laughed out loud so hard at the beginning of the scene when you find out that Michael is asleep and driving. Yeah. It was so funny. I also laughed out loud when Dwight says he made Michael a mixed CD, something he can
哦，我为此感到非常自豪。非常好。所以安吉拉，你提到德怀特和迈克尔在一起开车。当发现迈克尔在开车时睡着了，我在场景开始时大声笑了出来。是啊。太搞笑了。当德怀特说他给迈克尔做了一张混音CD时，我也大声笑了出来，如果他带女人回房间，他可以播放。我的意思是，德怀特是个僚机，伙计们。我太喜欢了，我觉得我们需要听听。你好，我叫德怀特·舒特。如果你正在听这个，你是一个迈克尔已经诱惑的幸运女人。啊，能穿上你的鞋子。接下来是什么？你可能在想，不要害怕你在天堂的夜晚。
play if he brings a woman back to his room. I mean, Dwight is a wingman, guys. I loved it so much, I felt like we needed to hear it. Hello, my name is Dwight Schrute. If you are listening to this, you're a lucky woman Michael has seduced. Ah, to be in your shoes. What's next? You're probably wondering, don't be scared of your night in heaven.
我的意思是，这太令人毛骨悚然了。最大程度的恐怖因素。这个场景让我笑是因为一些我没预料到的事情，珍娜。什么？我笑得停不下来。我不知道为什么。也许我只是心情很疯。我不知道这是不是故意的，但你注意到迈克尔的穿着
I mean, it's so creepy. Maximum creep factor. This scene made me laugh for something I was not expecting, Jenna. What? I couldn't stop cracking up. I don't know why. Maybe I was just in a loopy mood. I don't know if it was intentional or not, but did you notice that Michael is dressed
和他车的座椅一模一样吗？什么？他穿得和车里的内饰一模一样。所以他全身米色，座椅也是米色，他就像一个米色的肉团在路上行驶，这让我笑喷了。我没注意到，但我得回去看看。嗯，伙计们，大家终于到了尼亚加拉。他们正驶入城市。
just like his car seat? What? He's dressed exactly like the upholstery in his car. So he's in all beige and the seat is all beige and he's just like a beige blob going down the road and it just cracked me up. I did not, but I want to go back and look at it. Well, you guys, the gang finally makes it to Niagara. They're pulling into the city.
对于每个人到达尼亚加拉的驾驶序列，凯利·坎特利分享说，那是拍摄的，珍娜，当你们从“雾中少女号”上擦干身体时。哦，哇。是啊。在很大程度上，我们在洛杉矶拍摄了这一集，酒店的所有场景都是在工作室城的运动家旅馆拍摄的。对于大堂区域，我们使用了一个正在翻修的区域，就在酒店后面。
For that driving sequence as everyone arrives to Niagara, Kelly Cantley shared, that was filmed, Jenna, while you guys were drying off from Made of the Mist. Oh, wow. Yeah. For the most part, we shot this episode in Los Angeles and all of the scenes at the hotel were shot at Sportsman's Lodge in Studio City. For the lobby area, we used an area that was under renovation that was kind of in the back of the hotel.
我们的美术指导迈克尔·加伦伯格和我们的布景师史蒂夫·罗斯坦，他们基本上把这个未使用的大堂变成了这个虚构的斯塔特勒瀑布酒店。多么了不起的工作。我的意思是，从壁炉到你看到的一切，他们都放进去了。一切。所有的酒店房间，它们都在二楼。那是酒店的一个未使用的侧翼，当时正在翻修。它们是空的。
Our production designer, Michael Gallenberg and our set decorator, Steve Rothstein, they basically turned this unused lobby into this fictitious Statler Falls hotel. What an amazing job. I mean, everything from like the fireplace, all of it that you see, they put in there. Everything. All the hotel rooms, they were upstairs on the second floor. It was an unused wing of the hotel that was undergoing a renovation at the time. They were empty.
所以字面上你看到的一切都是我们的设计团队添加的，我觉得这太神奇了。而且女士，你还记得我们和艾德·赫尔姆斯谈论他刚开始在《办公室》工作时，他住在运动家旅馆吗？是啊，那是他们安置他的地方。是的。顺便说一句，当我和李结婚时，运动家旅馆就在我们家街下，我们发现你可以买他们游泳池的日票。
So literally everything you see was added by our design crews, which I just think is amazing. And lady, do you remember when we talked to Ed Helms about when he started on the office, he stayed at Sportsman's Lodge. Yeah, that's where they put him up. Yes. Incidentally, when Lee and I got married, Sportsman's Lodge was down the street from our house and we found out that you could buy a day pass for their swimming pool.
他们有一个巨大的游泳池，就像奥林匹克规格的游泳池。所以每当我的家人来城里时，我们就会买运动家旅馆游泳池的日票。珍娜，我爸爸喜欢运动家旅馆。我们会去那里游泳和闲逛。你和我经常在那里见面吃早餐，因为他们有很棒的早餐。他们有一个很棒的小早餐餐馆之类的东西。是啊。
They have a huge swimming pool, like an Olympic-sized swimming pool. And so whenever my family would come to town, we would get day passes for the Sportsman's Lodge swimming pool. Jenna, my dad loved the Sportsman's Lodge. We would go there and swim and hang out. And you and I often met there for breakfast because they had a fantastic breakfast. They had an amazing little breakfast diner restaurant thing. Yeah.
嗯，兰迪还和我分享说，我们在运动家旅馆拍摄时，必须为我们即将到来的一集进行剧本围读。他们把我们放在这个会议室里，但它有一个巨大的窗户正对着游泳池。我们有很多围观者，很多穿着泳衣和毛巾的人走过，看着我们读《办公室》的一集。还要试着集中注意力阅读和说台词，就像某个家伙穿着泳裤在追逐一个沙滩球一样。
Well, Randy also shared with me that we had to do a table read for one of our upcoming episodes while we were shooting at Sportsman's Lodge. And they put us in this conference room, but it had a huge window right onto the swimming pool. We got a lot of look-y-loose, a lot of people in their bathing suits and towels just walking by watching us read an episode of the office. Also try concentrating on reading and delivering a line as like some guy is chasing after a beach ball in his swim trunks.
嗯，现在吉姆和帕姆要去酒店房间办理入住手续了。我想让你们看看8分41秒。大堂里有一张漂亮的照片，一张巨大的尼亚加拉大瀑布的照片，真正的瀑布。嗯，那是我们自己的迈克尔·加伦伯格拍的。兰迪和迈克尔去那里踩点。在他们的踩点之旅中，迈克尔拍了那张照片，把它放得很大，并把它作为大堂装饰的一部分。
Well now Jim and Pam are going to check in to their hotel room. And I want you guys to look at eight minutes 41 seconds. There is a beautiful photo, a huge picture in the lobby of Niagara Falls, of the actual falls. Well, that was taken by our very own Michael Gallenberg. Randy and Michael had gone there to scout. And on their scouting trip, Michael took that picture and blew it up really big and made it part of the lobby decoration.
哦，我喜欢那个细节。在这个场景中，吉姆和帕姆明确表示他们今晚要开单独的房间，然后第二天晚上他们要入住蜜月套房。但他们想知道，我们能看一眼吗？我们只是想看看。酒店前台职员说，哦，抱歉。今晚有人住那个房间。那个人就是安迪。
Oh, I love that detail. During this scene, Jim and Pam make it clear that they're going to get individual rooms tonight and then the next night they're going to check into the honeymoon suite. But they're wondering like, could we just take a peek at it? We just want to look at it. And the hotel desk clerk is like, oh, I'm sorry. Someone has that room tonight. And that someone is Andy.
安迪在前一天晚上住在蜜月套房，他说，我会为你们先试用一下。约翰说了这句台词。它在剧本里。我不得不查一下，因为他做的方式太搞笑了。我以为也许他是即兴发挥的。他只是说，我不喜欢那样。我不喜欢那样。
Andy is staying in the honeymoon suite the night before and he's like, I'll break it in for you guys. John delivers this line. It was in the script. I had to look it up because the way he did it was so funny. I thought maybe he made it up on the fly. He just says, I do not like that. I do not like that.
太棒了。嗯，听着，我有一个我心心念念的客串明星警报。在这一集中扮演前台职员的女人是我的朋友，米歇尔·冈恩。现在，我认识米歇尔很久了，她在获得这个角色之前为《办公室》试镜了六次，扮演了六个不同的角色。我不知道。是的，她会进入最后的复试，然后他们会把角色给别人。
It's so great. Well, listen, I have a guest star alert that is near and dear to my heart. The woman who plays the front desk clerk throughout this episode is my friend, Michelle Gunn. Now, I have known Michelle for so long and she auditioned for the office six times for six different roles before landing this one. I didn't know that. Yes, and she would get to the final callbacks and then they'd give the role to someone else.
但爱丽丝·琼斯一直让她回来。当她没得到角色时，我们总是很沮丧。但后来她得到了这个巨大的角色，她可以和几乎每个演员互动。她由保罗·费格执导，她还因为两集不同的剧集获得了报酬。所以我们太兴奋了。我们就像，天哪，这就是那个故事，就像你没得到的每一份工作都通向你注定要拥有的工作。多有趣。
But Alice and Jones kept bringing her back. We would always be so bummed when she didn't get a role. But then she got this huge role where she got to interact with almost every cast member. She got to be directed by Paul Feig and she got paid for two different episodes. So we were so excited. We were like, oh my gosh, this is that story where like every job you didn't get leads to the job you absolutely were meant to have. How fun.
而且她在里面演得太好了。她太棒了。哦，她演得太好了。我想让你知道我注意到了场景中的一个背景捕捉，安吉拉。非常快。你发现了什么？好的。有一个小公告板，上面写着所有其他
And she's so good in it. She's so good. Oh, she crushed it. I want you to know I noticed a background catch in the scene, Angela. It's really quick. What'd you got? Okay. There is like a little announcement board that sort of says all the other things that
在这一晚酒店发生的事情。哦，上面写着什么？好的。顺便说一句，我为这个而活，我很遗憾我错过了它，所以我迫不及待地想听。嗯，除了吉姆和帕姆的彩排晚宴，你还可以参加晚上7点在麋鹿厅举行的驼鹿小屋会议，或者下午5点在河流厅举行的老年人扑克周五。或者也许你想去晚上8点在接待大厅举行的奥布莱恩退休派对。
are happening at the hotel on this night. Oh, what's it say? All right. I live for this, by the way, and I'm sad I missed it, so I cannot wait to hear. Well, in addition to Jim and Pam's rehearsal dinner, you could also attend the Moose Lodge meeting at 7 p.m. in the Elk Room or Senior Poker Friday at 5 p.m. in the River Room. Or perhaps you'd like to go to the O'Brien Retirement Party at 8 p.m. in the reception hall.
我还注意到了这个花絮。我知道吉姆和帕姆的婚礼招待会是什么时候，因为它在板子上。是第二天下午2点在瀑布厅。所以他们有一个，我想，就像一个新式的婚礼。嗯，当有人试图办理酒店入住时，会得到一些坏消息，那个人就是迈克尔，因为我想他以为你可以直接出现并说你想要一个比斯利-哈尔珀特预订的房间。然后你就会有一个房间。
I also noticed this tidbit. I know exactly when Jim and Pam's wedding reception is because it's on the board. It's 2 p.m. the next day in the Falls Room. So they had like, I guess, like a new-nish wedding. Well someone's going to get some bad news when they try to check into the hotel and that person is Michael because I guess he thought you could just show up and say you want a room with the Beasley Helpert block. And you would have a room.
这不是那样运作的。哦，迈克尔。所以迈克尔要试图挤进别人的房间。当然没人想要迈克尔在他们的房间里。唯一一个足够好心说迈克尔你可以睡另一张床的人是托比，而迈克尔就像，嗯，见鬼不，托比。我知道。你知道，斯坦利要来办理入住，带的不是他的妻子辛西娅，由阿尔杰里塔·温-刘易斯饰演。这有点丑闻。我很惊讶安吉拉对此没什么可说的。安吉拉沉迷于帕姆在怀孕时结婚的事实。她几乎无法专注于任何其他事情。没错。她把所有的羞耻感都集中在那一个方向上。我喜欢迈克尔走到吉姆和帕姆面前问，他什么时候做演讲，并
That's not how it works. Oh, Michael. So Michael's going to try to weasel himself into other people's rooms. Of course no one wants Michael in their room. The only person who's nice enough to say Michael you could have the other bed is Toby, and Michael's like, um, hell no, Toby. I know. You know, Stanley's going to arrive to check in with not his wife, Cynthia, played by Algerita
说，因为他想第三个上场，清理残局。是啊。这就是我们要第一次见到吉姆父母的地方。我们有佩里·史密斯饰演的贝齐·哈尔珀特和罗伯特·派恩饰演的杰拉尔德·哈尔珀特，他是演员克里斯·派恩的父亲。人们太兴奋了。我们有点兴奋。首先，他是一个非常非常可爱的人，对每个人都很好。
Win-Lewis. This is a bit scandalous. I'm surprised Angela didn't have something to say about this. Angela was consumed with the fact that Pam was getting married while pregnant. She could barely focus on anything else. That's right. She was focusing all her shame in that one direction. I love that Michael goes up to Jim and Pam and asks, when is he making his speech and
但有几个人对克里斯·派恩的父亲在那里感到兴奋。这是真的。尽管罗伯特·派恩本身就是一位非常成功的演员。我知道。嗯，听着，帕姆和吉姆正在向吉姆的父母指出曾祖母。她说，曾祖母是那个穿着青色衣服和妈妈说话的女人。现在，这对一些观众来说很困惑，因为，你知道，我们在第二季的性骚扰那一集中见过帕姆的妈妈。
says, because he'd like to go third to bat clean up. Yeah. This is where we are going to meet Jim's parents for the first time. We have Betsy Helpert played by Perry Smith and Gerald Helpert played by Robert Pine, who is the father of actor Chris Pine. People were so excited. We were a little bit excited. First of all, he's a lovely, lovely person and was so nice to everyone.
而我们见到的那个帕姆的妈妈并没有站在那个穿青色衣服的女人旁边，因为在这一集中，帕姆有一个新妈妈。我们不得不选一位新女演员来演帕姆的妈妈。是啊。最初扮演帕姆妈妈的女演员是香农·科克伦。她当时在巡回演出一部戏。她在演《奥古斯都：奥色治郡》，我们没法让她来演这一集。兰迪实际上谈到了这一点。
But there are a few folks excited that Chris Pine's dad was there. It's true. Even though Robert Pine is like an incredibly successful actor in his own direction. I know. Well, listen, Pam and Jim are pointing out Mima to Jim's parents. She says, Mima is the woman in teal talking to my mom. Now, that was confusing to some viewers because, you know, we met Pam's mom in the sexual harassment episode in season two.
他说这一集很难安排，因为我们有这么多不同的客串明星，其中许多是我们之前剧集中确立的。我们必须找同样的人。我们甚至不得不在两个周六拍摄。我不知道你是否记得，安吉拉，但为了让每个人都在同一个房间里参加婚礼部分，我们实际上在周六拍摄。我们没能请到的那个人是香农。编剧们谈到了这一点。
And the woman that we met as Pam's mom was not standing over by the woman in teal because in this episode, Pam has a new mom. We had to cast a new actress as Pam's mom. Yeah. The original actress who played Pam's mom was Shannon Cochran. She was on tour doing a play. She was doing Augusto Sage County and we could not get her for this episode. Randy actually talked about this.
他们觉得我们必须让帕姆的妈妈参加婚礼。他们没有……当然。就像，我们不能没有她妈妈就结婚。不。他们不想制造某种帕姆妈妈没来的戏剧性冲突。对。此外，他们真的想引入迈克尔和帕姆妈妈之间的故事情节。
He said this was a really difficult episode to schedule because we had so many different guest stars, many of whom we had established in previous episodes. We had to get the same people. We even had to shoot on two Saturdays. I don't know if you remember that, Angela, but in order to get everybody in the same room together for the wedding part, we actually shot on Saturdays. The one person we couldn't get was Shannon. The writers talked about this.
那是这一季的一个重要故事情节。而且看起来香农的巡演日程也会和那个冲突。所以他们决定重新选角。帕姆的新妈妈由琳达·珀尔饰演。当我见到她时，我真的很惊讶我们看起来有多像。很有趣，因为最初的女演员香农看起来有点像我真正的妈妈，但我认为琳达看起来有点像我。我实际上认为她看起来像是我姐姐，我们在做数学题
They felt that we had to have Pam's mom at the wedding. They did not... Of course. Like, we could get married without her mom. No. They did not want to manufacture some kind of drama like that Pam's mom didn't come. Right. Plus, they really wanted to introduce that storyline between Michael and Pam's mom.
我们就像，等等，实际上，我们年龄差距没那么大。她生我的时候应该是19岁。有一点好莱坞魔法，有一点凑合。他们试图用她的发型、化妆和服装来掩盖这一点。但这里有一件疯狂的事。她演戏演了很久了。她曾出演过《快乐时光》。那有多酷？
And that was an important storyline for this season. And it looked like Shannon's tour schedule was going to bump into that as well. So they made the decision to recast the role. Pam's new mom was played by Linda Pearl. When I met her, I was really struck with how alike we look. It's funny because the original actress, Shannon, kind of looks like my real mom, but I thought Linda looked kind of like me. I actually thought she looked like she could be my big sister and we were doing the math
那不疯狂吗？嗯，琳达很令人愉快。我喜欢和她一起工作。在11分3秒，人们正走向彩排晚宴的地方。有一个牌子写着“比斯利-哈尔珀特”。现在哈尔珀特拼错了。当时互联网上的一些人就像，天哪，他们把吉姆的姓
and we were like, wait, actually, like we're not that far apart in age. She would have been 19 when she had me. A little bit of Hollywood magic there, a little fudging. They tried to play it up with like her hair makeup wardrobe. But here's something crazy. She's been acting for forever. She had been on happy days. How cool is that?
拼错了。维塔在评论音轨中分享说，那是故意的。那就像一个小玩笑，一个小隐藏的吉姆，一个小彩蛋，你知道，酒店员工把他的名字拼错了。所以那是故意的，伙计们。是的，安吉拉，在我之前提到的那个小牌子上，每次它应该写哈尔珀特时，它都写成哈尔珀特。这就像一个持续的笑话。
Isn't that crazy? Well, Linda was delightful. I loved getting to work with her. At 11 minutes, three seconds, people are making their way into where the rehearsal dinner is. There is a sign that says Beasley Halpert. Now Halpert is spelled wrong. And some people on the internet at the time were like, oh my gosh, they spelled Jim's last
你可以找到很多哈尔珀特。牌子上的其他信息是这样写的：婚礼彩排晚宴，晚上7点到8点40分。是啊，伙计们，你们得离开。得离开。8点40分。你们得走。你们有一个小时40分钟。吃吧。
name wrong. Vada shared on the commentary, that was intentional. That was like a little joke, a little hidden Jim, a little nugget, you know, that the hotel staff had spelled his name wrong. So that was meant to be, you guys. Yes, Angela, on that little sign that I mentioned earlier, every time it's supposed to say Halpert, it says Halpert. It's like a running joke.
做你的祝酒词。维塔在激情套餐房举行。哇。嗯哼。我可以告诉你，我们是在伯班克著名的牛排屋餐厅拍摄所有这些彩排晚宴场景的。我不知道你是否记得，安吉拉，当时我住在离牛排屋步行距离之内。
You can find many Halprits. The other information on the sign reads like this, wedding rehearsal dinner, 7 to 8.40 PM. Yeah, guys, you've got to get out. Got to get out. 8.40. You're out. You have an hour and 40 minutes. Eat up.
你可以找到很多哈尔普里特。牌子上的其他信息是这样写的：婚礼彩排晚宴，晚上7点到8点40分。是的，伙计们，你们得离开。必须离开。8点40分。你们就得走。你们有一个小时40分钟的时间。快吃吧。
Make your toast. Vada is taking place in the Passion Package Room. Wow. Mm-hmm. I can tell you that we filmed all of these rehearsal dinner scenes at the famous Smokehouse restaurant in Burbank. I don't know if you remember, Angela, but at the time I lived in walking distance from the Smokehouse.
发表你们的祝酒词。瓦达的婚礼在激情套餐房举行。哇。嗯哼。我可以告诉你，我们是在伯班克著名的烟屋餐厅拍摄了所有这些彩排晚宴的场景。安吉拉，我不知道你还记不记得，当时我就住在离烟屋步行距离之内的地方。
Oh, you were so excited when we were filming there. I would walk home for lunch and I'd have lunch with Lee. It was so great. Guys, listen, the Smokehouse is a very famous restaurant. It is right across the street from Warner Brothers Studios, so a lot of movie executives and actors eat there. I guess George Clooney even named his production company after the Smokehouse restaurant. Yeah, because he filmed on the Warner Brothers lot and he would walk over there.
哦，我们在那里拍摄的时候你太兴奋了。我会走路回家吃午饭，然后和李一起吃。那真是太棒了。伙计们，听着，Smokehouse 是一家非常有名的餐厅。它就在华纳兄弟制片厂的街对面，所以很多电影高管和演员都在那里吃饭。我想乔治·克鲁尼甚至以 Smokehouse 餐厅的名字命名了他的制作公司。是的，因为他在华纳兄弟的场地拍摄，他会走过去。
That's the Hollywood lore, anyway. Well, the original Smokehouse only seated 46 people. I found a whole little video documentary about it and I thought we should listen to a little audio clip about its history. Great. The original Smokehouse was started here at Riverside and Pass in Burbank in 1946 by two Lockheed engineers, Jim Stockton and Jack Monroe. Jim was the promoter and frontman and Jack was the cook.
总之，这就是好莱坞的传说。嗯，最初的 Smokehouse 只有 46 个座位。我找到了一个关于它的完整小纪录片，我想我们应该听一段关于它历史的音频片段。太棒了。最初的 Smokehouse 是 1946 年由两位洛克希德工程师吉姆·斯托克顿和杰克·门罗在伯班克的河滨路和帕斯路口创办的。吉姆是发起人和门面，杰克是厨师。
Opening night was attended by such neighborhood luminaries as Bob Hope and Bing Crosby. Soon after, all 46 seats were regularly filled to capacity and it was time to look for larger quarters. As fate would have it, the Redcoach Inn, built by Danny Kaye but never opened, was available and in 1948 became the permanent home of the Smokehouse. By 1952, Jim's younger brother Stan was running the restaurant and chef John L. Sullivan's unique recipe for garlic bread made the Smokehouse the largest purveyor of French bread west of the Mississippi.
开业之夜，鲍勃·霍普和宾·克罗斯比等社区名流出席了。不久之后，所有 46 个座位经常座无虚席，是时候寻找更大的地方了。正如命运安排的那样，由丹尼·凯建造但从未开业的 Redcoach Inn 刚好空着，并于 1948 年成为 Smokehouse 的永久家园。到 1952 年，吉姆的弟弟斯坦在经营这家餐厅，厨师约翰·L·沙利文独特的蒜蓉面包配方使 Smokehouse 成为密西西比河以西最大的法式面包供应商。
Yeah, like their garlic bread was like the thing. It's still the thing. It brought in all the celebs. I guess the new location could seat like 500 people. Here's a list of the people that would go to the Smokehouse for this bread. Errol Flynn, Judy Garland, Robert Redford. But the Smokehouse was known for respecting the privacy of celebrities. They would never sell a story to the tabloids.
是的，他们的蒜蓉面包就像是招牌。现在依然是。它吸引了所有的名人。我想新店址可以容纳大约 500 人。这是一份会去 Smokehouse 吃这种面包的人员名单。埃罗尔·弗林、朱迪·加兰、罗伯特·雷德福。但 Smokehouse 以尊重名人隐私而闻名。他们从不出售故事给小报。
And when I first moved to Los Angeles, Angela, I had a friend who told me that once a week they would go eat lunch at the Smokehouse to try to get discovered by executives who were coming there for lunch. It never happened. They never, they never got discovered. I just want that guy in the ad to do something for office ladies. Two girls. Angela Fink, Jenna Fisher, Sam Kiefer, Cassie Jerkins, Sitting Around, Talking About TV.
安吉拉，当我刚搬到洛杉矶时，我有一个朋友告诉我，他们每周会去 Smokehouse 吃一次午饭，试图被来那里吃午饭的高管发现。这从未发生过。他们从来没有，从来没有被发现。我只是希望广告里的那个人能为办公室女士们做点什么。两个女孩。安吉拉·芬克，珍娜·费舍尔，萨姆·基弗，卡西·杰金斯，坐在一起，谈论电视。
You get a sense of like the mood of the Smokehouse when you listen to that. For sure. Well, I think we should take a break and when we come back Dwight is going to hold court at the kids table and we're going to meet Pam's sister. Oh yeah. What? Pam has had a sister this whole time? Yeah.
当你听那个的时候，你会感觉到 Smokehouse 的氛围。当然。嗯，我想我们应该休息一下，当我们回来时，德怀特将在儿童桌旁主持大局，我们将见到帕姆的妹妹。哦，是的。什么？帕姆一直有个妹妹？是的。
And she's like a famous actress. We'll be back. We are back. And I can't wait because we're about to talk to Mimaw. Oh, yes, Mimaw played by the amazing Peggy Stewart. First of all, I just want to say that I loved the detail that Mimaw had her napkin tucked into her blouse like a bib. Did you notice this?
而且她还是个著名的女演员。我们马上回来。我们回来了。我等不及了，因为我们马上要和米玛谈谈。哦，是的，米玛由了不起的佩吉·斯图尔特饰演。首先，我只想说，我喜欢米玛把餐巾像围兜一样塞进衬衫里的细节。你注意到了吗？
I did. She wasn't going to mess up her outfit. No, she was not. I bet she also has a little rain bonnet for her hair. My grandma had one of those because, you know, she would go get her hair done once a week at the salon and they tease it all up. Angela Martin had one. Mimaw says that Pam marrying Jim might just be restoring her faith in that side of the
我注意到了。她不想弄脏她的衣服。不，她没有。我打赌她头发上还有一个小雨帽。我奶奶有一个，因为你知道，她每周会去沙龙做一次头发，他们会把头发梳得高高的。安吉拉·马丁有一个。米玛说帕姆嫁给吉姆可能正在恢复她对那一边的信心。
family. And Pam's kind of like, oh, thanks, Mimaw, I mean, nobody's perfect, but, you know. And then Mimaw says she wouldn't care to live if she thought that was true. Pam's Mimaw is Angela. I know. You know, when we were talking to Greg, Greg mentioned that Peggy Stewart, who played Mimaw, was in a whole bunch of westerns. But I mean, like, I can't even tell you how many she was in.
家庭。帕姆有点像，哦，谢谢，米玛，我是说，没有人是完美的，但是，你知道。然后米玛说如果她认为那是真的，她就不想活了。帕姆的米玛是安吉拉。我知道。你知道，当我们和格雷格交谈时，格雷格提到饰演米玛的佩吉·斯图尔特演过一大堆西部片。但是我是说，我甚至无法告诉你她演了多少部。
Just from 1944 to 1951, just for that seven years, she was in 35 westerns. Oh my gosh. In seven years. Yeah. She also has a ton of television credits, like she was on Gunsmoke for five years. She's been on the A team, Days of Our Lives, Seinfeld, Frazier. She died recently. In 2019, she was 95 years old.
仅从 1944 年到 1951 年，仅仅那七年，她就演了 35 部西部片。天哪。在七年里。是的。她还有大量的电视作品，比如她在《荒野大镖客》里演了五年。她还演过《天龙特攻队》、《我们的日子》、《宋飞正传》、《欢乐一家亲》。她最近去世了。2019 年，她 95 岁。
She was a delight. She was amazing. Everyone loved her on set. She completely held her own with her scenes with Steve. Oh, don't even get me started. I can't wait to get to those. I know. I know.
她真是个令人愉快的人。她太棒了。片场每个人都爱她。她在和史蒂夫的对手戏中完全撑住了场面。哦，别让我开始说这个。我等不及要讲到那些了。我知道。我知道。
How lucky were we? Pam's going to run into her dad and his much younger new girlfriend, Christy Kelly. Pam's dad was played by Rick Overton. Remember the last time we saw him, he was just down in the parking lot with just some off-camera dialogue. Here he is. He's back. He was so fun.
我们多幸运啊？帕姆要撞见她爸爸和他年轻得多的新女友克里斯蒂·凯利了。帕姆的爸爸由里克·奥弗顿饰演。还记得我们上次见到他时，他只是在停车场里，只有一些画外音对话。他在这儿。他又回来了。他太有趣了。
He's back. And then Dwight is at the kids' table. He is. And Dwight is just crushing it with the kids. Well, he's doing that fun thing where he's not talking down to them, which makes an adult fascinating to children. Right. And we see at 11 minutes, 52 seconds, Charlotte Daniels, Greg's daughter, who I thought did
他又回来了。然后德怀特在儿童桌旁。他是。德怀特在孩子们中间简直如鱼得水。嗯，他在做那件有趣的事，他没有居高临下地和他们说话，这让成年人对孩子来说很迷人。对。我们在 11 分 52 秒看到夏洛特·丹尼尔斯，格雷格的女儿，我觉得她表现得
fantastic. Oh, my gosh. Yes. And later, she's going to dance down the aisle. Yes. She's got a whole other big moment. And then, Jenna, up next, we're going to meet Pam's sister. I know we have a lot to share about this.
太棒了。天哪。是的。后来，她还要在过道上跳舞。是的。她还有另一个大场面。然后，珍娜，接下来，我们要见到帕姆的妹妹了。我知道我们有很多关于这个的要分享。
I could not believe in sort of the canon of the show up to this point that Pam would have such a cute, fun sister. And it's never come up. None of the guys, Michael, would be constantly like, Pam, is your sister going to stop by? When's your sister stopping by? Like, I feel like Pam has Pam hidden the fact that she has such a cute sister because she knows all the fellas will be like just bugging her. Angela, 100%.
我简直不敢相信在目前为止的剧集正典中，帕姆会有这样一个可爱、有趣的妹妹。而且从来没提过。那些家伙，迈克尔，会一直问，帕姆，你妹妹要过来吗？你妹妹什么时候过来？我觉得帕姆是不是隐瞒了她有一个这么可爱的妹妹的事实，因为她知道所有的男人们都会一直缠着她。安吉拉，百分之百。
I am convinced that everyone at this wedding from Dunder Mifflin is shocked that Pam has a sister, shocked. I love it that she mistakes Kevin for Oscar's boyfriend, Gil. And Oscar is like, what, what? He is so offended. He's so angry. During the scene, I have two background catches. One is behind Kevin and Oscar, did you see the enormous picture of Jim and Pam in a golden
我确信婚礼上所有来自邓德·米夫林的人都对帕姆有妹妹感到震惊，震惊。我喜欢她把凯文误认为是奥斯卡的男朋友吉尔。奥斯卡当时就，什么，什么？他太冒犯了。他太生气了。在这一幕中，我有两个背景发现。一个是凯文和奥斯卡身后，你看到那个巨大的吉姆和帕姆的照片了吗，在金色的
frame on an easel? Yes. I remember taking that. I just remember that from going to weddings. Everyone has that one picture, like their engagement picture in a big frame. Yeah. I love that little detail. That's hanging somewhere, Jenna.
画框里，放在画架上？是的。我记得拍过那个。我只记得去参加婚礼时见过这个。每个人都有那一张照片，就像他们的订婚照放在一个大画框里。是的。我喜欢那个小细节。那东西挂在某处，珍娜。
Someone has that. Yeah. Someone has that giant, it's probably in a warehouse. Also in the background, Kelly pointed out that the fire that's in the fireplace making everyone feel so cozy, fakey fire. What do you mean, fakey fire? It's special effects because there was no fire in the fireplace at the smokehouse when we filmed.
有人有那个。是的。有人有那个巨大的，可能在仓库里。背景里还有，凯利指出壁炉里的火让每个人都感觉很舒适，那是假火。你什么意思，假火？那是特效，因为我们拍摄时 Smokehouse 的壁炉里没有火。
What? That is blowing my mind. I know. It looks really good. I should probably give you a little guest star breakdown on Pam's sister, who was played by the lovely Anna Camp. You guys know Anna. She's been on Mad Men.
什么？这让我大吃一惊。我知道。看起来真的很棒。我应该给你做一个关于帕姆妹妹的客串嘉宾介绍，她由可爱的安娜·坎普饰演。你们认识安娜。她演过《广告狂人》。
She's been on the Mindy Project. She was the star of the Pitch Perfect movies. I was so excited when she came to set because I had been watching True Blood and she had a great story arc on True Blood. Oh, yeah. I reached out to her and she sent in some audio clips about her time on the show. Of course, we started by asking her how she got the role of Penny. Hi there.
她演过《明迪烦事多》。她是《完美音调》电影的主演。当她来到片场时我太兴奋了，因为我一直在看《真爱如血》，她在《真爱如血》里有一个很棒的故事线。哦，是的。我联系了她，她发来了一些关于她在剧组时间的音频片段。当然，我们首先问她是如何得到佩妮这个角色的。嗨。
This is Anna Camp and I'm super excited to be on the Office Ladies podcast. I had the pleasure of playing Pam's sister Penny in the wedding episodes in Niagara and I had the best time. It was truly an honor to get to be a part of those episodes. Yeah, how I got the job. I had auditioned for Alison Jones, who's incredible casting director multiple times for lots of different things and she was always very supportive of me and always remained a fan and I could tell that she was trying to find me something.
我是安娜·坎普，我非常兴奋能参加《办公室》播客。我有幸在尼亚加拉的婚礼剧集中饰演帕姆的妹妹佩妮，我度过了最美好的时光。能参与这些剧集真是我的荣幸。是的，我是怎么得到这份工作的。我多次为艾莉森·琼斯试镜，她是位出色的选角导演，她为很多不同的事情试镜，她一直非常支持我，一直保持着粉丝身份，我能看出她一直在试图为我找点什么。
I was actually doing a play in New York at the time, so I got an audition for Penny and I had to go all the way up to 30 Rockefeller Plaza and it's a super iconic feeling when you go up to audition at NBC in New York City. I remember there were like two scenes that I did for the casting director up there on top of 30 Rock and at the time, the character Penny was also the character who hooks up with Dwight at the wedding, so at the time it wasn't two characters because my friend Kellan Coleman, who I actually met on that Office episode, she played the character, the other bridesmaid who hooks up with Dwight, so they come split my role in two.
当时我实际上正在纽约演一部戏，所以我得到了佩妮的试镜机会，我不得不一路去到洛克菲勒中心 30 号，当你去纽约市 NBC 试镜时，那是一种超级标志性的感觉。我记得我为那里的选角导演演了两场戏，在 30 号大楼顶上，当时，佩妮这个角色也是在婚礼上和德怀特勾搭上的角色，所以当时并不是两个角色，因为我的朋友凯兰·科尔曼，我实际上是在那集《办公室》里认识她的，她饰演了那个角色，另一个和德怀特勾搭上的伴娘，所以他们把我的角色一分为二了。
I'm not really sure why they did that because I was like, oh man, that would have been super fun. I love Rainn Wilson. He's so funny. But anyway, I made a really great friend out of Kellan and we're still friends today. That was a news flash to me. Yeah, I didn't know that. So originally they were going to have Pam's mom hook up with Michael and Pam's sister
我不太确定他们为什么要那样做，因为我当时想，哦天哪，那会超级有趣的。我爱雷恩·威尔逊。他太搞笑了。但无论如何，我通过凯兰交到了一个非常好的朋友，我们今天仍然是朋友。这对我是个新闻。是的，我不知道。所以最初他们打算让帕姆的妈妈和迈克尔勾搭上，让帕姆的妹妹
hook up with Dwight. What? That was too much of a one-two punch. You cannot do that to Pam. I'm so glad that instead had Pam's friend hook up with Dwight, I guess, but wow, crazy, crazy, that her audition sides were different. We also asked her how she felt about getting the job, what it was like to be part of this episode, and here's what she had to say.
和德怀特勾搭上。什么？那太猛烈了。你不能那样对帕姆。我很高兴他们改为让帕姆的朋友和德怀特勾搭上，我想，但是哇，疯狂，疯狂，她的试镜台词是不一样的。我们还问了她得到这份工作后的感受，参与这一集是什么感觉，这是她要说的。
I just remember being so excited to be on the episode and wearing Bridesmaid's dresses and all of that and being directed by Paul Feig was just super exciting. I was originally a fan of the show, so of course, I was already up to date with everything that had been going on and I was a huge fan of the cast and just thought the writing was so superb. And I just remember seeing these characters that I had been watching. They're like, I mean, obviously I'm an actor, but there's something like a little, I was very starstruck seeing everybody hanging out and doing their thing and just like these
我只记得能参加这一集感到非常兴奋，穿着伴娘礼服等等，由保罗·费格执导真是超级令人兴奋。我最初是这部剧的粉丝，所以当然，我已经了解了所有发生的事情，我是演员阵容的超级粉丝，只是觉得剧本太棒了。我只记得看到这些我一直在看的角色。他们就像，我是说，显然我是个演员，但有一些像一点点，看到每个人都在闲逛做他们的事情，就像这些
iconic characters, just people being people and being funny and improving and hanging out on their phones, talking. It was just such a fun thing for me to be a part of pretty early on in my career. And I still see those wedding photos and I'm like in them, like how did I get to be in the wedding episode of the office and like, I'm Bridesmaid, pretty, pretty surreal. Okay, I have to say that when she was talking about like seeing all these people that she had seen on TV, just kind of like walking around, being on the phone, just being themselves, like how surreal that could be.
标志性的角色，只是人们做着自己，变得有趣，即兴发挥，在手机上闲逛，聊天。这对我职业生涯早期来说是一件非常有趣的事情。我仍然看到那些婚礼照片，我心想我在里面，就像我怎么能参加《办公室》的婚礼剧集，而且我是伴娘，太，太超现实了。好吧，我必须说，当她谈到看到所有这些她在电视上见过的人，只是像走来走去，在打电话，只是做他们自己，那有多超现实。
That totally took me back to the fact that Angela, one of my very first acting jobs, was in the movie Geely. Do you remember this movie? Was that Ben Affleck? And Jennifer Lopez. And I had a scene with Christopher Walken. Get out! Yes, where he's in an elevator and then I enter the elevator and it has a funny smell and
这完全让我想起了安吉拉，我的第一份表演工作之一，是在电影《鸳鸯绑匪》里。你记得这部电影吗？那是本·阿弗莱克？和詹妮弗·洛佩兹。我和克里斯托弗·沃肯有一场戏。走开！是的，他在电梯里，然后我进入电梯，里面有一种奇怪的味道，然后
I have to comment to my friend about the smell and like was just like a little like three line scene. Are you in that movie? If I go watch that movie, I've never seen it. I think I made the cut. I think I'm in the movie. It was just crazy because I was like, as Christopher Walken, I'm doing a scene with Christopher Walken.
我不得不向我的朋友评论那个味道，就像是一个只有三句台词的小场景。你在那部电影里吗？如果我去看那部电影，我从来没看过。我想我入选了。我想我在电影里。这太疯狂了，因为我当时想，那是克里斯托弗·沃肯，我正在和克里斯托弗·沃肯演对手戏。
Oh my God. Christopher Walken. How is this happening? And then like, I didn't have any scenes with Ben Affleck or Jennifer Lopez, but like, you know, you just see them like walk by in the far distance from their trailer. And you know, it was one of my very first jobs in Hollywood. And I just was like, I was in a dream state. It was so weird.
哦，天哪。克里斯托弗·沃肯。这是怎么发生的？然后，我没有和本·阿弗莱克或詹妮弗·洛佩兹的对手戏，但是，你知道，你只是看到他们从他们的拖车里走过，在远处。你知道，这是我在好莱坞的第一份工作之一。我当时就像，我处于梦境状态。太奇怪了。
I do want to say, shout out to Christopher Walken. They shot his coverage first, which is pretty standard. You shoot the stars. And then they said to him, Mr. Walken, you can go ahead and go to lunch while we get these ladies. We can have someone else read your line off camera. And he said, no, no, I stay for all my work. Oh my gosh, I love that.
我确实想说，向克里斯托弗·沃肯致敬。他们先拍了他的覆盖镜头，这很标准。你先拍明星。然后他们对他说，沃肯先生，您可以去吃午饭，同时我们拍这些女士。我们可以让别人在镜头外读您的台词。他说，不，不，我留下来完成我所有的工作。哦，天哪，我喜欢那个。
Yeah. And he stayed and he did the lines for us, even though he wasn't on camera. And I was like, okay, that was classy. I'm going to remember that. That was super cool. I have a Christopher Walken impression. What? From the movie True Romance.
是的。他留下来了，即使他不在镜头里，他也为我们读了台词。我当时想，好吧，那很有格调。我会记住那个。那太酷了。我有一个克里斯托弗·沃肯的模仿。什么？来自电影《真实罗曼史》。
I love that movie. What? What? True Romance. You have a Christopher Walken impression? From True Romance. Okay. I did not know this about you.
我喜欢那部电影。什么？什么？《真实罗曼史》。你会模仿克里斯托弗·沃肯？来自《真实罗曼史》。好吧。我不知道你还会这个。
You're my best friend and you can do a Christopher Walken impression. I really can't. I just love this movie. Okay. Here's Christopher Walken and True Romance. Okay. I love the son, the f**khead that he is. Oh.
你是我最好的朋友，你会模仿克里斯托弗·沃肯。我真的不会。我只是喜欢这部电影。好吧。这是《真实罗曼史》里的克里斯托弗·沃肯。好吧。我爱那个儿子，那个混蛋。哦。
That's it. That's it. That's as far as it goes. I mean, it's good. It's respectable. Thank you. Thank you. Wow.
就是这样。就是这样。这就是全部了。我是说，这很好。很体面。谢谢。谢谢。哇。
Your son. Come on. That movie is so good. We have gotten on a tangent here. How did that happen? Me and you on a tangent? What? So, listen, Anna Camp also mentioned how doing this role was one of her earliest jobs
你的儿子。得了吧。那部电影太棒了。我们在这里跑题了。那是怎么发生的？我和你跑题了？什么？所以，听着，安娜·坎普还提到做这个角色是她最早的工作之一
because after this, she would get her role on Glee and then she was going to have a regular role on the Mindy Project. She said that when she was auditioning for the Mindy Project, Mindy remembered her from meeting her doing Niagara and that Mindy really fought for her to get the role in a really meaningful way. So, she felt like, you know, she was able to plant a lot of seeds by doing this small role on our show and guys, she's just the loveliest. She also has the cutest dogs on the planet.
因为在这之后，她得到了《欢乐合唱团》的角色，然后她要在《明迪烦事多》里担任常规角色。她说当她为《明迪烦事多》试镜时，明迪记得她在尼亚加拉拍摄时见过她，明迪真的以一种非常有意义的方式为她争取到了那个角色。所以，她觉得，你知道，她通过在我们剧集中扮演这个小角色种下了很多种子，伙计们，她真是最可爱的人。她还有这个星球上最可爱的狗。
You can check them out and her on her Instagram at the real Anna Camp. Anna, thank you so much for sharing your memories and you were just wonderful and that was so great just to hear your voice. Well now, Ryan is hitting on a lady and Meredith is actively sabotaging him in just the best way. I loved it. I know. When you worked at the bowling alley, Kelly Kentley shared that for our props department,
你可以在她的 Instagram @therealannacamp 上查看它们和她。安娜，非常感谢你分享你的回忆，你真是太棒了，听到你的声音真是太好了。好吧，现在，瑞安正在勾搭一位女士，梅雷迪思正在以最好的方式积极破坏他。我喜欢它。我知道。当你在保龄球馆工作时，凯利·肯特利分享说，对于我们的道具部门，
the continuity of this rehearsal dinner scene was such a challenge because we shot out of order. So, in one scene, Mima might have her salad and the next scene, Andres and we were bouncing all around and our props department had to keep track of all of it. You know what? I remember that and they also have to keep track of which plate goes to which person. It is like a massive, massive undertaking to fake feed all of those people with a passage of time.
这个彩排晚宴场景的连续性是一个巨大的挑战，因为我们是乱序拍摄的。所以，在一个场景中，米玛可能在吃沙拉，下一个场景，安德烈斯，我们到处跳着拍，我们的道具部门必须跟踪所有这些。你知道吗？我记得那个，他们还必须跟踪哪盘菜给哪个人。这就像一个巨大的、巨大的任务，要在时间流逝中假装喂饱所有人。
With a three course meal. Yeah. Angela, I have a fan question. It's from Rachel B. in Austin, Texas. She says, around 12 minutes, 30 seconds. Why is Creed lurking over Andy's shoulder for his whole conversation? This is great. Rachel, I can tell you why.
吃三道菜的饭。是的。安吉拉，我有一个粉丝问题。来自德克萨斯州奥斯汀的瑞秋·B。她说，大约 12 分 30 秒。为什么克里德在安迪的整个谈话中都潜伏在他的肩膀后面？这太棒了。瑞秋，我可以告诉你为什么。
So this is really funny to me for many reasons. One is in the DVD commentary, Greg said in editing that he saw Creed creeping into the shot and he was like, why is Creed here? He has no lines in the script. What is he doing? Why has Paul placed him here? Because Greg wasn't there the day that we shot that. Paul Feig said the only thing he can think of is that they kept trying to place Creed
所以这对我来说很有趣，原因有很多。一个是 DVD 评论中，格雷格说在剪辑时，他看到克里德潜入镜头，他当时想，为什么克里德在这里？他在剧本里没有台词。他在做什么？为什么保罗把他放在这里？因为格雷格拍摄那天不在那里。保罗·费格说他唯一能想到的是，他们一直试图把克里德
in all these random places in the background because there was a deleted runner that didn't make it in that Creed, I guess, remembered being at this one restaurant because he used to smuggle back in the day and this was one of his meetup places and there's a really funny clip. Sam, can you play it? I know this place. So it's home-based when I rent cigarettes over the border. For whom, Oppisters?
放在背景中所有这些随机的地方，因为有一个被删掉的跑龙套情节没能放进去，克里德，我想，记得在这个餐厅里，因为他过去常常走私，这是他的见面地点之一，有一个非常有趣的片段。萨姆，你能播放一下吗？我知道这个地方。所以这是我走私香烟过境时的基地。为了谁，奥普斯特？
I never knew. The balloon went in, the balloon came out, I didn't think to ask. He smuggled cigarettes in a balloon in his body, full of cigarettes in a balloon? What? I don't know, apparently, and then there were more scenes where Creed was in the background looking for his stash and in one he finds it, there's a spy shot that got deleted where Creed is taking off the cushion in one of the little banquette seating booths and digs his hand way back in the booth and pulls out a bunch of cash and cigarettes and he looks
我从来不知道。气球进去了，气球出来了，我没想过要问。他把香烟装在气球里放在身体里，身体里装满了气球里的香烟？什么？我不知道，显然，然后还有更多克里德在背景中寻找他的藏匿处的场景，在一个场景中他找到了，有一个被删掉的偷拍镜头，克里德在其中一个小宴会座位区拿掉垫子，把手伸进座位深处，掏出一大把现金和香烟，他环顾四周
around and he puts some in his pocket and he sneaks off. I had no idea. And so if you see Creed lurking about in these rehearsal dinner scenes, that was this deleted runner of him looking for his stash. Lady, are you ready for some speeches? Oh, there's going to be so many. They're kicked off by Pam's friend, Isabel. And I got this fan question, by the way.
然后把一些放进兜里，溜走了。我完全不知道。所以如果你看到克里德在这些彩排晚宴场景中潜伏，那就是他寻找藏匿处的被删掉的跑龙套情节。女士，你准备好听演讲了吗？哦，会有很多。由帕姆的朋友伊莎贝尔开始。顺便说一句，我收到了这个粉丝问题。
Sophia Bee from Massachusetts says, Angela, you mentioned your daughter, Isabel, on the podcast before and Sophia is wondering if they named Pam's friend, Isabel, after your daughter, Isabel. Do you know? They sure did. We filmed this episode in 2009. My daughter was around a year old and the character, Isabel Pariba, who was Pam's friend, her name was a combination of my daughter's first name and Paul Lieberstein's wife's
来自马萨诸塞州的索菲亚·B 说，安吉拉，你之前在播客上提到过你的女儿伊莎贝尔，索菲亚想知道他们是不是以你女儿伊莎贝尔的名字命名帕姆的朋友伊莎贝尔。你知道吗？他们确实是。我们 2009 年拍摄了这一集。我女儿大约一岁，角色伊莎贝尔·帕里巴，也就是帕姆的朋友，她的名字是我女儿的名字和保罗·利伯斯坦妻子的
maiden name, Isabel Pariba. Hey, well, the real Isabel was played by Kellan Coleman. She has been on the newsroom, Big Little Lies, the Mindy Project. We love her and she's going to come back. She did four episodes of the office. She was fantastic. Well, now Jim's brothers are going to give a speech. You might remember, we've met them before.
娘家姓的组合，伊莎贝尔·帕里巴。嘿，好吧，真正的伊莎贝尔由凯兰·科尔曼饰演。她演过《新闻编辑室》、《大小谎言》、《明迪烦事多》。我们爱她，她会回来的。她演了四集《办公室》。她太棒了。好吧，现在吉姆的兄弟们要演讲了。你可能记得，我们之前见过他们。
They're played by Tug Coker and Blake Robbins. Tug told me that he improvised the line, A Little Moe Cardio. And he said that they were a little more confident improvising this time around since they'd been on the show before. And he said that that little line is the thing that people text and DM him more than anything else in reference to him being on the show. It's like the thing that stood out in their toast to me. For sure.
他们由塔格·科克和布莱克·罗宾斯饰演。塔格告诉我，他即兴发挥了那句“一点点莫有氧运动”。他说，因为他们之前参加过这部剧，这次即兴发挥时他们更有信心了。他说，那句小台词是人们发短信和私信他最多的东西，关于他参加这部剧。对我来说，那是他们祝酒词中最突出的东西。当然。
Well, Michael thinks their speech is inappropriate and he's going to save the day. He's going to jump in and you guys, at 14 minutes, 28 seconds, did you notice that Michael delivers his joke about the smart car with his eyes closed? Yes. I loved that choice so much. His eyes are closed for about 20 seconds. Michael Feig shared in the commentary that this was a choice that Steve made and Paul was like, okay, and Steve just committed to it and did it.
好吧，迈克尔认为他们的演讲不合适，他要拯救局面。他要跳出来，伙计们，在 14 分 28 秒，你们注意到迈克尔闭着眼睛讲关于智能汽车的笑话了吗？是的。我非常喜欢那个选择。他的眼睛闭了大约 20 秒。迈克尔·费格在评论中分享说，这是史蒂夫做出的选择，保罗当时说，好吧，史蒂夫只是投入其中并做到了。
Did you notice that Mima puts her hand up to her ear to try to hear better? I did. And also, I would like to point out that Mima is not at the head table. She is not sitting next to Pam, Pam's mother and Pam's sister. They have not allowed her at the head table for some odd reason. Odd reason. I think we all know what reason. Listen, there are so many fun background catches in this rehearsal dinner.
你注意到米玛把手放在耳朵上试图听得更清楚了吗？我注意到了。而且，我想指出米玛不在主桌。她没有坐在帕姆、帕姆的母亲和帕姆的妹妹旁边。出于某种奇怪的原因，他们没有让她坐在主桌。奇怪的原因。我想我们都知道是什么原因。听着，这个彩排晚宴里有很多有趣的背景发现。
I mean, little things like I notice when Jim starts giving his speech, Pam's mom hugs Pam's sister and they share a little loving look like everybody is in their character and they are contributing these real amazing reactions to this scene. It is so rich. I love it. So layered. Michael's whole smart car thing, it's going to bomb. Pam looks over at Jim like step in and Jim does and he does such a great job up until
我是说，一些小细节，比如我注意到当吉姆开始演讲时，帕姆的妈妈拥抱了帕姆的妹妹，她们分享了一个充满爱意的眼神，就像每个人都在角色中，他们为这个场景贡献了这些真实而惊人的反应。它太丰富了。我喜欢它。层次分明。迈克尔的整个智能汽车的事情，要搞砸了。帕姆看着吉姆，好像在说介入，吉姆做了，他做得很好，直到
the end. He doesn't. Yeah. Yeah, it's really sweet. He's saying really sweet things and Pam's going to take a little mental picture. Jenna Veta shared that whole bit about teaching you how to drive a stick was improvised. Oh, wow. Way to go, John Krasinski.
最后。他没有。是的。是的。这真的很甜。他说了一些非常甜的话，帕姆要拍一张心理照片。珍娜·维塔分享了关于教你如何开手动挡的整段戏是即兴发挥的。哦，哇。干得好，约翰·卡拉辛斯基。
I know, but then you responded right in the moment too, so you're right there with him. And Andy crying. Talk about just one of the things in the background, Andy crying in Jim's speech. I absolutely love. I know. That was just, that's Ed making the choice for his character and our cameras picking these up. Well, listen, Jim is going to like end his toast by asking everyone to raise their glasses
我知道，但你当时也立刻回应了，所以你和他在一起。还有安迪在哭。谈谈背景中的事情之一，安迪在吉姆的演讲中哭泣。我绝对喜欢。我知道。那是，那是埃德为他的角色做出的选择，我们的摄像机捕捉到了这些。好吧，听着，吉姆要以让大家举杯来结束他的祝酒词
except Pam, of course. And Mima was like, why of course? By the way, Mima was hearing at that point was spot on. Yeah, exactly. She's hearing all of this and you know, Jim is like, oh, you know, for, she can do whatever she wants, you know, but she shouldn't drink because she's an alcoholic. Wait, what? No, she's not.
当然除了帕姆。米玛当时说，为什么当然？顺便说一句，米玛当时的听力非常准确。是的，没错。她听到了这一切，你知道，吉姆说，哦，你知道，对于，她想做什么就做什么，你知道，但她不应该喝酒，因为她是酒鬼。等等，什么？不，她不是。
She's just, I don't know. Pam's dying and Jim is like, she's pregnant. So then Michael's going to try to help. Of course he is. And lady, I watched this three times because it was so funny to me and I think we have to hear it. This is Michael trying to help Jim and Pam. Okay.
她只是，我不知道。帕姆快死了，吉姆说，她怀孕了。所以迈克尔要试着帮忙。当然他会。女士，我看了三遍，因为它对我来说太搞笑了，我想我们必须听听。这是迈克尔试图帮助吉姆和帕姆。好吧。
Okay. Okay. Okay. Hey, what I think Jim is trying to say is that they had an accident and you know what? These two people, they're living together. They are having lots of consensual sex. They were living together? Yes.
好吧。好吧。好吧。嘿，我想吉姆想说的是他们出了个意外，你知道吗？这两个人，他们住在一起。他们有很多自愿的性行为。他们住在一起？是的。
Yes. They were living together. Yes. And you know what? You can't expect them to be careful every time because frankly it's just a different sensation. Michael. Am I wrong?
是的。他们住在一起。是的。你知道吗？你不能指望他们每次都小心，因为坦率地说，这只是不同的感觉。迈克尔。我错了吗？
They say it's not different, but it's a different sensation when you use something to block. I think everybody knows what I am talking about. It's not necessarily different for the woman, but it is different. Okay. Okay. Michael. Stop. All right.
他们说那不一样，但当你用东西阻挡时，感觉是不一样的。我想每个人都知道我在说什么。这对女性来说不一定不同，但确实不同。好吧。好吧。迈克尔。停下。好吧。
My point is, I said what I wanted to say and Mima, I hope you heard every word. Okay. So I just want to say that Steve definitely embellished some of that. Like in the script, they had that whole thing about, you know, they're living together and having regular sex and Mima's like they're living together. And then Michael was just supposed to say, yes, and they can't be expected to be careful every single time. You know, it's a different sensation, but then it was going to kind of end there.
我的观点是，我说出了我想说的话，米玛，我希望你听到了每一个字。好吧。所以我只想说，史蒂夫绝对润色了一些。比如在剧本里，他们有关于，你知道，他们住在一起并有规律的性生活，米玛说他们住在一起。然后迈克尔本应该说，是的，不能指望他们每次都小心。你知道，这是一种不同的感觉，但然后就应该在那儿结束了。
So all that stuff about like, I mean, maybe not for the woman, but I think you know what I'm talking about, like all of that just like awkward innuendo and extra was us playing in the moment. Well, I remember how hard it was not to laugh during this moment. And Kelly Cantley talked about it on the commentary. She was like, we had to make announcements to the room, not just our regular cast, but all of our background performers. You guys, you can't laugh.
所以所有关于，我是说，也许对女性来说不是，但我认为你知道我在说什么，所有那些尴尬的暗示和额外的东西都是我们在那一刻的发挥。好吧，我记得在这个时刻不笑有多难。凯利·肯特利在评论中谈到了这一点。她说，我们不得不向房间里的人宣布，不仅仅是我们的常规演员，还有我们所有的背景表演者。伙计们，你们不能笑。
You guys can't laugh because we all kept cracking up and we're all supposed to be horrified. Right? Like, oh my gosh, Michael. Michael's speech here did not help, but he is going to save the day. Pam tells them, guys, Mima's leaving. She's not coming to the wedding. Yeah. But Michael is going to go to Mima's hotel room.
伙计们你们不能笑，因为我们一直在笑，而我们本应该感到震惊。对吧？就像，哦，天哪，迈克尔。迈克尔在这里的演讲没有帮助，但他要拯救局面。帕姆告诉他们，伙计们，米玛要走了。她不来参加婚礼了。是的。但迈克尔要去找米玛的酒店房间。
And what I love about the scene so much is that you are, you're predisposed to be like, oh my God, Michael, stop making it worse. But then he's like the Mima whisperer. When he starts off, I was a little worried because he was like, look, Mima, women have sex all the time now. You got to just, you know what, you got to let that go. And you're like, where's this going? But then they end up finding some common ground and he helps her turn off her television,
我非常喜欢这个场景的一点是，你，你倾向于觉得，哦，天哪，迈克尔，别让事情变得更糟了。但后来他就像米玛的耳语者。当他开始时，我有点担心，因为他说，看，米玛，现在女性一直有性生活。你得，你知道吗，你得放手。你当时想，这要往哪儿去？但后来他们找到了共同点，他帮她关掉了电视，
which was making her crazy. So my grandma in real life was a little persnickety and opinionated and she ran a little negative. And the family, we would just be like, oh my gosh, you know, here she goes. I had this one boyfriend and I don't know what it was, but he would do what Michael did. He would be like, grandma, you got to let that go. Now that's just nonsense. And she would giggle.
这让她发疯。所以我的奶奶在现实生活中有点挑剔和固执己见，她有点消极。家里人，我们只会说，哦，天哪，你知道，她又来了。我有过一个男朋友，我不知道是什么，但他会做迈克尔做的事。他会说，奶奶，你得放手。那只是胡说八道。她会咯咯笑。
She'd be like, oh, okay, okay. And we were like, what? This is the, what? How are you unlocking grandma right now? This is incredible. We were in awe. And that when I watched the scene, it reminded me of that. Well, my grandmother, who I love so much, but you know, she did not watch the office.
她会说，哦，好吧，好吧。我们当时想，什么？这是，什么？你是怎么在这一刻解锁奶奶的？这太不可思议了。我们感到敬畏。当我看到这一幕时，它让我想起了那个。好吧，我的奶奶，我非常爱她，但是你知道，她不看《办公室》。
She didn't care for it. She didn't care for it, thought Michael Scott was vulgar. So proud for you, will not watch it. At 19 minutes, 16 seconds, there is a Michael talking head out in the hallway after he's left Meemaw's room. Paul Feig shared that they shot that at the end of the day. And then the next morning when they got to set, Steve was like, guys, we need to reshoot it.
她不喜欢它。她不在乎，认为迈克尔·斯科特很粗俗。为你感到骄傲，不会看它。在 19 分 16 秒，迈克尔离开米玛房间后，走廊里有一个迈克尔的谈话头。保罗·费格分享说，他们是在一天结束时拍摄的。然后第二天早上当他们到达片场时，史蒂夫说，伙计们，我们需要重拍。
Why? Well, I guess there was a line that just kept bumping Steve. And he was like, guys, I just think it's a little too much. When they first filmed it, Michael refers to grandma's friend as Myrtle. The scripted line was this. I'm actually great with old women. In fact, for the longest time, my best friend was my grandma. And then she met Myrtle.
为什么？好吧，我想有一句台词一直让史蒂夫感到困扰。他说，伙计们，我只是觉得这有点过分了。他们第一次拍摄时，迈克尔把奶奶的朋友称为默特尔。剧本台词是这样的。我其实很擅长和老女人相处。事实上，很长一段时间，我最好的朋友是我奶奶。然后她遇到了默特尔。
And now she thinks she's better than everybody. And for whatever reason, the name Myrtle. Steve was like, it's just too much. And they changed it to Harriet. And that's the line that made it in. Oh my gosh. I love that Steve was so committed to just getting the nuance of that joke right. Now we're going to head on down to the bar where everyone is kind of looking to have
现在她认为她比任何人都好。不管什么原因，默特尔这个名字。史蒂夫说，这太过了。他们把它改成了哈丽特。那就是最终采用的台词。哦，天哪。我喜欢史蒂夫如此致力于把那个笑话的细微差别弄对。现在我们要去酒吧，每个人都在寻找
a good time the night before the wedding. We shot all these bar scenes in the bar of the Sportsman's Lodge. Incidentally, we did a table read in the bar as well one day. We were just table reading all over this place. This was two weeks of wonky crazy table reads. It really was. But they were really fun. And Pam wants to get in on this.
在婚礼前夜玩得开心。我们在 Sportsman's Lodge 的酒吧拍摄了所有这些酒吧场景。顺便说一句，有一天我们也在酒吧里进行了剧本朗读。我们到处都在进行剧本朗读。这是两周古怪疯狂的剧本朗读。确实是。但它们真的很有趣。帕姆想参与其中。
She wants to go down to the bar maybe. She's going to leave her room wearing her very giant necklace and big hoop earrings and her bangle bracelets. But she's going to run into Angela. Oh yeah. Emma's not the only fun stopper in town. Angela's here too. At 21 minutes 12 seconds, the hallway where this scene takes place was not a real hallway.
她想去酒吧也许。她要离开房间，戴着她非常巨大的项链和大的圆圈耳环以及她的手镯。但她会撞见安吉拉。哦，是的。艾玛不是城里唯一的扫兴者。安吉拉也在这儿。在 21 分 12 秒，这个场景发生的走廊不是一个真正的走廊。
I remember shooting this, Angela. Yes. It was a fakie hallway. It was a tiny nook. And we had to cheat it to look like a hallway. And they told you and I to hug the wall. So if you watch the scene, we're standing super close to the wall the whole time. And there wasn't a lot of wiggle room.
我记得拍摄这个，安吉拉。是的。这是一个假走廊。那是一个小角落。我们不得不作弊让它看起来像走廊。他们让你和我贴着墙。所以如果你看这个场景，我们一直站得离墙超级近。没有太多的活动空间。
Like we couldn't walk far in either direction because we ran out of wall. Yeah. Well, Angela is going to talk Pam out of going to the bar. By offering to go with her to the bar. And basically just chaperone her for the night with like a judgy sneer the whole time. So Pam's like, I'm out. Yeah. At 21 minutes 34 seconds, we see the famous howling at the moon t-shirt that Dwight is
就像我们不能向任何方向走远，因为我们没墙了。是的。好吧，安吉拉要劝帕姆不要去酒吧。通过提议和她一起去酒吧。基本上就是整晚监视她，全程带着评判的冷笑。所以帕姆说，我不去了。是的。在 21 分 34 秒，我们看到了德怀特要穿去接女士们的著名的对着月亮嚎叫的 T 恤。
going to wear to pick up the ladies. Yeah. Paul and Greg talked about Dwight's t-shirt in the commentary. I guess our wardrobe department just bought it online and you can still buy this exact t-shirt. It's on Amazon. What? Yes.
是的。保罗和格雷格在评论中谈到了德怀特的 T 恤。我想我们的服装部门只是在网上买了它，你仍然可以买到这件一模一样的 T 恤。它在亚马逊上。什么？是的。
But guess what else? In May of 2009, someone wrote a customer review that went viral. Brian Govren gave the t-shirt five out of five stars. His prose were fits my girthy frame has wolves on it attracts women cons only three wolves could probably use a few more on the guns cannot see wolves when sitting with arms crossed wolves would have been better if they glowed in the dark and 41,274 people found this review helpful. Um, that is fascinating, Angela.
但你猜还有什么？2009 年 5 月，有人写了一篇走红的客户评论。布莱恩·戈夫伦给了这件 T 恤五星好评。他的评价是：适合我粗壮的身材，上面有狼，吸引女性，缺点只有三只狼，可能在枪上还需要几只，双臂交叉坐着时看不到狼，如果狼在黑暗中发光会更好，41,274 人觉得这篇评论有帮助。嗯，这太迷人了，安吉拉。
I am particularly fascinated by the fact that this review came out before this t-shirt ever appeared on our episode. I know. Wow. Pretty amazing. Guys, you can have the wolf shirt. I kind of want one. I know.
我特别着迷于这篇评论出现在这件 T 恤出现在我们剧集之前的事实。我知道。哇。太神奇了。伙计们，你们可以拥有狼恤。我有点想要一件。我知道。
I was thinking that too. I was like, do I need the wolf shirt but on a mug? Maybe I do. Well, you know, who doesn't seem to mind Dwight's howling at the moon shirt? Who? Pam's friend, Isabelle. And she finds all of Dwight's chatter about his horses and farm. So interesting.
我也在想那个。我当时想，我需要狼恤但印在杯子上吗？也许我需要。好吧，你知道，谁似乎不介意德怀特的对着月亮嚎叫的 T 恤？谁？帕姆的朋友，伊莎贝尔。她觉得德怀特关于他的马和农场的所有闲聊都很有趣。
Yeah. The fact that he has nine and three quarter horses. How is that possible? He explains. I invented a device called Burger on the Go. It allows you to obtain six regular sized hamburgers or 12 sliders from a horse without killing the animal. George Foreman is still considering it.
是的。他有九匹半马的事实。这怎么可能？他解释说。我发明了一种叫“随身汉堡”的装置。它允许你从马身上获得六个普通大小的汉堡或 12 个小汉堡，而无需杀死动物。乔治·福尔曼还在考虑它。
Sharper Image is still considering it. Sky Mall is still considering it. Hamakashlema is still considering it. Sears said no. Well, when Greg saw this scene in editing, he was like, wait, that was a list of alternates. Greg meant for only one of these to be used. Instead, because he wasn't there, they thought it was a list so Dwight ends up saying all of them.
Sharper Image 还在考虑它。Sky Mall 还在考虑它。Hamakashlema 还在考虑它。西尔斯说不。好吧，当格雷格在剪辑中看到这个场景时，他说，等等，那是一份备选清单。格雷格本意是只使用其中一个。相反，因为他不在那里，他们以为那是一个清单，所以德怀特最终把它们全说了。
But then they actually ended up liking it so they left them all in. We're going to go to Andy's room next because the party is in full swing. I want to remind you this is the honeymoon suite that Andy has for one night. And Randy Cordray shared with us that our set designers had originally designed this huge heart shape kind of like hot tub bathtub that was going to be in the room as kind of like an homage to the honeymoon suite. Well, they had design meetings. They made it.
但后来他们实际上最终喜欢上了它，所以他们把它们全留下了。接下来我们要去安迪的房间，因为派对正在如火如荼地进行。我想提醒你们，这是安迪住一晚的蜜月套房。兰迪·科德雷和我们分享说，我们的布景设计师最初设计了一个巨大的心形热水浴缸，本来要放在房间里，作为对蜜月套房的一种致敬。好吧，他们开了设计会议。他们做了它。
They even had pitched the idea that that's where Michael sleeps because he doesn't have a room. He sleeps in the heart tub. It was in the room. You never see it. It never made it on camera. It was huge and they built it in the corner and you never see it. No.
他们甚至提出了迈克尔睡在那里的想法，因为他没有房间。他睡在心形浴缸里。它在房间里。你从来没看到它。它从来没进镜头。它很大，他们在角落里建了它，你从来没看到它。不。
So there's this huge dance-off happening in this room. Andy and Meredith are kind of doing like a robot challenge. Kelly's like, what else you got? Because you know Kelly and Andy have a history of a dance-off. Well, guess what? Andy's going to do the splits and he's going to hurt himself. He can't get back up, y'all. Because he hurt his TT.
所以这个房间里发生了一场巨大的舞蹈比赛。安迪和梅雷迪思有点像在进行机器人挑战。凯利说，你还有什么？因为你知道凯利和安迪有舞蹈比赛的历史。好吧，你猜怎么着？安迪要劈叉，他要伤到自己。他站不起来了，伙计们。因为他伤到了他的蛋蛋。
Yeah, his scrote got hurt. He did. You know, Paul shared that Ed pitched that he thought just the splits wouldn't do that much damage that Andy should have something in his pocket that he lands on. Oh, that was a good idea. Yeah. Aaron and Kevin are going to carry Andy to Pam's door. Pam, the bride.
是的，他的阴囊受伤了。他确实。你知道，保罗分享说，埃德提出他认为仅仅劈叉不会造成那么大的伤害，安迪应该在口袋里放点什么，他落地时会撞到。哦，那是个好主意。是的。亚伦和凯文要抬着安迪去帕姆的门口。帕姆，新娘。
She's the sober one. Everyone else has been partying. I get that. I mean, listen, it's horrible timing for Pam. No doubt about it. Well, she's got to drive Andy to the hospital. That's how this episode ends with that news on Pam's doorstep. Listen, we had one fan question that I wanted to address.
她是清醒的那一个。其他人都在派对。我明白。我是说，听着，这对帕姆来说时机太糟糕了。毫无疑问。好吧，她得开车送安迪去医院。这一集就是以帕姆门口的那个消息结束的。听着，我们有一个粉丝问题我想解决。
Amy C. from Charlotte, North Carolina said, my kids who are nine and 11 noticed that Daryl wasn't at the wedding in Niagara. Where was he? Great catch. Amy, tell your kids we're very proud of them over here on Office Ladies. Yeah. So here's what it was. It was decided that since Daryl was a close friend of Pam's ex-fiance Roy, Pam and Jim
来自北卡罗来纳州夏洛特的Amy C.说，我那9岁和11岁的孩子注意到Daryl没有参加尼亚加拉的婚礼。他在哪儿呢？问得好。Amy，告诉你的孩子们，我们《办公室女士》节目组为他们感到骄傲。是的。情况是这样的，当时决定因为Daryl是Pam的前未婚夫Roy的好友，所以Pam和Jim
would not have invited anyone from the warehouse, including Daryl, to the wedding. But I'm pretty sure the reason they had to come up with that idea is because Craig was in New Orleans filming a movie at this time. Well, that's 100% why he's not there. Yeah. You know, Jim and Daryl are going to become good friends and they're going to be part of an upstart business together in later seasons. But right now, that hasn't happened yet.
不会邀请仓库里的任何人，包括Daryl参加婚礼。但我敢肯定，他们想出这个理由是因为Craig当时正在新奥尔良拍电影。嗯，那百分之百是他不在那儿的原因。是的。你知道，Jim和Daryl之后会成为好朋友，在后面的几季里他们还会一起创业。但现在，这一切还没发生。
Right now, that's sort of like Pam's ex-world. Yeah. Well, that is Niagara part one, you guys. We're ending with an injured scrotum. We'll be back next week. We have so much to talk about next week. I mean, we haven't gotten to the ceremony. We haven't gotten to the actual falls.
现在，那算是Pam过去世界的一部分。是的。好了，这就是《尼亚加拉》的第一部分。我们以一个受伤的阴囊结束了这一集。我们下周回来。下周我们有太多要聊的了。我是说，我们还没讲到婚礼仪式，还没讲到真正的瀑布呢。
There's more to say. We hope you guys have a great week. Thanks for listening and sending in your questions and your comments. Huge thank you to Greg Daniels for being our guest today. And another big thank you to Randy Cordray, who really helped us dissect the ins and outs and background of this episode. Randy, we thank you so much. Thank you, Randy.
还有很多要说的。希望大家这周过得愉快。感谢你们的收听，也感谢你们发来的问题和评论。非常感谢今天的嘉宾Greg Daniels。还要特别感谢Randy Cordray，他真的帮我们剖析了这一集的来龙去脉和背景。Randy，非常感谢你。谢谢你，Randy。
He's also going to be helping us next week. He is the best. And thank you to Anna Camp for sending in audio clips. We love you guys. Bye. Love you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
他下周也会继续帮助我们。他真是太棒了。还要感谢Anna Camp发来的音频片段。我们爱你们。再见。爱你们。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、Jenna Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作。
Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的节目执行制片人是Cody Fisher。我们的制片人是Cassie Jerkins。我们的音响工程师是Sam Kiefer。我们的助理制片人是Ainsley Bubico。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton演唱的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。使用优惠码OFFICE即可获得Stitcher Premium一个月的免费试用。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。